Rồi các bạn, hôm qua chúng ta nói xong
về cái phần các cái magic của bài toán
ân loại đúng không?
Chúng ta nói về acquacy, nói về
precision, chúng ta nói về recall, chúng
ta nói về F1 là các cái matric dành cho
các cái tạo ra các cái giá trị cụ thể
đúng không? Do chúng ta nói về hai cái
magic nữa là chúng ta nói về
ờ ROC và AUC đúng không? ROC là receiver
operating receiver operating
characteristic. Thế còn AOUC là error
under the curve đúng không? Thì cái ROC
là cái đường màu vàng. Còn AUC là cái
phần diện tích tạo ở bên dưới này. Tạo ở
bên dưới tạo phần màu vàng với cả cái
trục chiều dương của trục Ox này đúng
không? Thì cái AOC nãy ra một cái giá
trị nắm khoảng từ 0 cho đến 1. Từ 0 cho
đến 1 càng gần 1 thì càng tốt, càng gần
0 thì càng tồi. Đúng không?
Cái đường màu đỏ này là cái một cái mô
hình mà chúng ta coi là một cái mô hình
ngẫu nhiên. Tức là nó cứ trung bình nó
cứ dự án hai thì nó đúng một sai một thì
nó sẽ ra cái đường này. Được chưa? Đúng
là như bạn nói là nếu mà cái
bộ rượu mà nó rất là mất cân bằng ấy thì
cái đường thì cái thì cái form rate nó
sẽ rất là bé. Lúc nào nó sẽ rất là bé
trong cái lúc nào cũng rất là lớn. Đúng
và như thế chúng ta hoàn toàn chúng ta
có thể đổi cái đường trục hoành ra một
cái matric khác. Thế nhưng mà nhìn chung
thì cái cách mà dùng true positive với
cả form này là cái cách mà phổ biến nhất
các bạn sẽ hay gặp nhất.
Thế thế thì hôm nay chúng ta sẽ sang một
cái phần mới. Chúng ta sẽ nói về chúng
ta sẽ nói về một cái pipeline. Một cái
pipeline trong quá trình chúng ta phát
triển một cái phát triển một cái ứng
dụng một cái bài một một cái một cái
project cái dự án về về machining thì nó
sẽ bao gồm những cái bước gì? Thì các
bạn nhìn nhá. Các bạn nhìn đây này.
Chúng ta có tổng cộng là chín cái bước
như này. Được chưa? Chúng ta có chín cái
bước như này. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ đi qua
đi qua một chút về từng cái bước một
chưa? một cái một cái bài toán, một cái
ứng dụng về machining trong thực tế nó
sẽ cần trải qua chín cái bước như này.
Thật ra nó phải có thêm cái bước nữa là
cái bước mà à đưa ra bài toán, đưa ra
vấn đề đúng không? Đưa ra yêu cầu đúng
không? Tức là ví dụ tôi muốn xây dựng
một cái mô hình dự đoán ra nhà, tôi muốn
xây dựng một cái ứng dụng dự đoán nhiệt
độ ngoài trời hay là dự đoán điểm của
sinh viên học sinh hay là dự đoán giá cổ
phiếu chứng khoán gì đấy đúng không?
Chúng ta phải có một cái bài toán đã
đúng không? Đầu tiên là phải có một cái
bài cái bài toán đã đúng không? Có bài
toán, có yêu cầu.
Bài toán về yêu cầu thường khi các bạn
đi học ấy thì nó sẽ đến từ giảng viên
hoặc là nó nó đến từ mình chẳng hạn. Ví
dụ như vậy hoặc là đến từ ai đấy đúng
không? Hoặc đến từ cái nhu cầu của công
việc. Thế lúc bạn đi làm thì thường nó
có thể đến từ sếp hoặc đến từ khách
hàng. Được chưa? Thế thế thì sau khi có
cái bài toán này rồi thì cái việc đầu
tiên các bạn sẽ cần làm đó là cái bước
là các bạn sẽ thu thập dữ liệu. Thu thập
dữ liệu đây là một trong cái những cái
sự khác biệt giữa môi trường à hàn lâm,
môi trường học thuật và môi trường đi
làm thực tế. Khi mà các bạn đi làm ấy,
khi mà đi học ấy, các bạn gần như các
bạn chả bao giờ các bạn phải lo cái bước
này cả. Tại vì khi bạn đi học trên
trường thì thường lúc các bạn mới bắt
đầu làm quen với AI, với machining thì
thường là
giáo giảng giảng viên sẽ cho các bạn một
cái bộ dữ liệu. Cho các bạn một cái bộ
dữ liệu. Thế hoặc là như các bạn học với
mình chẳng hạn, mình sẽ cho các bạn bộ
dữ liệu. Các bạn cũng chả cần quan tâm
là cái bộ rượu nó đế nó đến từ đâu. Các
bạn cũng chẳng cần quan tâm là làm sao
để có cái bộ rượu đấy. Các bạn chỉ quan
tâm là có một cái bộ dữ liệu để tôi làm
việc cùng đúng không? Ví dụ bây giờ mình
muốn các bạn làm quen với việc là xây
dựng mô hình để dữ ấn giá nhà đi thì
mình sẽ cho các bạn một cái bộ rượu về
nhà có diện tích, có số tầng, có cái nội
thất các thứ và có giá của căn nhà đó.
Các bạn cũng chẳng cần quan tâm đến rượu
đến từ đâu. Các bạn chỉ biết là tôi dùng
bộ rượu này tôi sử dụng mô hình ra thôi.
Được chưa? Thì đây cái bước đầu tiên
trong môi trường hàn lâ học thuật các
bạn sẽ gần như các bạn không phải khe
cái bước này. Trừ phi. Trừ phi đến lúc
mà các bạn làm khóa luận hoặc làm được
đồ án tốt nghiệp thì các bạn sẽ phải lo
cái bước này. Thì lúc với các bạn sẽ
phải chọn cái topic rồi các bạn đi thu
hợp dữ liệu thế nào đấy. Thế mà lúc các
bạn có đang đi học thì gần như không
phải lo bữa này. Đấy. Thế nhưng mà khi
mà các bạn đi làm thì đây sẽ là một
trong số những bước nó tốn rất là nhiều
thời gian. Nó khá là nhàm chán. Nó khá
là nhàm chán. Nó cũng không yêu cầu các
bạn phải có cái kiến thức đặc thù gì về
AI cả. Thu hợp dữ liệu chỉ đơn giản các
bạn đi lấy dữ liệu ở một cái nguồn nào
đấy thôi đúng không? Nó không yêu cầu
các bạn phải có kiến thức chuyên môn Hàn
Lâm gì học thuật gì quá là ghê gớm. Nó
khá là nhàm chán nhưng nó cũng đồ nó rất
là quan trọng. Tại vì nếu không có dữ
liệu thì sẽ chẳng có những cái bước sau.
Nếu không có cái bước này sẽ chẳng có
những cái bước sau. Được chưa? Và thuộc
dữ liệu này thì nó sẽ mô hình vạn trạng.
Ví dụ là cái rượu bạn nó là rượu dạng
bảng đi. Ví dụ công ty các bạn có một
cái
data warehouse ở đâu đấy các bạn dùng
SQL để các bạn truy cập vào. Các bạn lấy
dữ liệu thì các bạn lọc liếc các thứ lấy
ra những cái liệu cần thiết đúng không?
Hoặc là ví dữ liệu các bạn ví dụ như bọn
mình bọn mình làm về công ty mình là bọn
mình làm về ảnh với video thì ví d hiệu
mình sẽ lưu trữ ở một cái nguồn khác như
bọ mình không lưu trữ trên SQL server
các thứ kiểu như vậy không lưu chữ trên
một cái post gì đấy mình sẽ có một cái
chỗ khác để mình để mình lưu trữ thế và
khi mà có rượu rồi thì các bạn cũng phải
quan tâm đến việc đánh nhãn nữa. Hầu hết
sau này các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ làm
việc với những cái bài toán supervised
learning là học có giám sát. Mà muốn làm
việc với học giám sát các bạn sẽ cần
phải có rượu có đánh nhãn. Thì đánh nhãn
như thế nào bây giờ? đánh nhãn nó sẽ có
môn hình vạn chạm.
Ví dụ như ngày xưa cái hồi mình ví dụ
các cái công ty của mình trước giờ nó sẽ
có nhiều kiểu. Một là có những cái công
ty mà họ sẽ có sẵn một cái team gọi là
team annotation ở sẵn trong công ty.
Team này thường là bao gồm các bạn sinh
viên đó các bạn đánh đánh nhãn. Thế có
những công ty có sẵn những cái team như
vậy hoặc công ty hiện tại của mình cũng
có sẵn một cái team annotation như vậy.
Hoặc là có những công ty họ sẽ làm việc
với một cái bên thứ ba. Ví dụ như là hồi
2021 hồi mình là một công ty cũng là về
màng thể thao giống công ty hiện tại thì
cái tas đầu tiên mà xếp ra cho mình đó
là gì? là tìm một công ty ở Việt Nam làm
về mảng data annotation để làm việc cùng
với nhau. Đấy thì h đấy bọn mình cũng
làm việc với công ty ở Việt Nam trong
suốt khoảng khoảng khoảng 4 năm rưỡ đấy
tức là các bạn có thể có một cái team
sẵn trong công ty hoặc các bạn thuê về ở
bên ngoài. Thế thật ra chúng ta ở Việt
Nam có một cái rất là may mắn đó là chi
phí. Tức là ở Việt Nam chúng ta thì cái
mảng data annotation là cái mảng rất là
phát triển. Ở Việt Nam, ở Trung Quốc, ở
Ấn Độ và ở các cái nước Châu Phi thì cái
bảng này rất là phát triển. Tại vì chúng
ta có
có có
thường cái chi phí nhân công nó giá rẻ.
Đấy, chi phí nó rất là rẻ. Đấy, thì cái
việc mà đánh nhanh dữ liệu nó sẽ nó sẽ
đỡ khó khăn hơn, nó sẽ đỡ tốn kém hơn,
tốn kém hơn. Thế thế đây là cái bước đầu
tiên. Bước này thường nó rất tốn rất là
nhiều thời gian các bạn. Tốn rất nhiều
thời gian bản thân ở công ty mình hiện
tại đây là bước rất là tốn thời gian.
Đấy, [khịt mũi] sau khi chúng ta có dữ
liệu rồi, chúng ta sẽ đến bước tiếp theo
là gì? Chúng ta sẽ thực hiện một vài
những cái thống kê. Thống kê để làm gì?
Thống kê để giúp chúng ta có thể hiểu dữ
liệu. Trước khi trước khi chúng ta muốn
có thể huấn luyện được một trong một cái
mô hình để nó làm việc với dữ liệu thì
bản thân chúng ta chúng ta phải chúng ta
phải hiểu về cái dữ liệu đấy đã đúng
không? Chúng ta mà không hiểu dữ liệu
thì làm sao mà chúng ta yêu cầu là mô
hình chúng ta phải hiểu dữ liệu được
đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải làm ra một
vài những cái thống kê. Thống kê ví dụ
là xem là chúng ta có những cái loại dữ
liệu gì đúng không? Mỗi một loại dữ liệu
nó có những cái liệu kỳ vọng phương sai,
độ lệnh chuẩn các thứ vân vân vân vân
đúng không? Những cái thứ mà các bạn học
môn số thống kê ấy. Đấy đấy cũng làm
chúng ta cũng sẽ áp dụng vào đây được
chưa? T đến khi nào chúng ta làm cái
phần này, chúng ta sẽ nói xem là có
những loại thống kê phổ biến nào. Được
chưa? Thế thống kê. Thống kê này giúp
chúng ta có thể hiểu dữ liệu hơn đúng
không? Trước khi chúng ta muốn huấn
luyện mô hình thì bản thân chúng ta phải
hiểu về dữ liệu cái đã.
Thì sau khi mà chúng ta hiểu về dữ liệu
rồi, chúng ta sẽ có bước tiếp theo là
gì? Là chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu chúng ta sẽ
thực hiện là tiền xử lý dữ liệu. Vì sao
chúng ta lại cần phải tiền xử lý dữ
liệu? Tại vì là nó có hai lý do. Lý do
thứ nhất là gì? là
máy móc nó khác với con người. Con người
chúng ta chúng ta có thể hiểu dữ liệu
dưới nhiều định dạng khác nhau. Chúng ta
có thể hiểu dữ liệu dướ dạng là dữ liệu
dạng bảng này, dữ liệu dạng văn bản này,
hình ảnh này, âm thanh này, video này.
Chúng ta có thể hiểu dưới nhiều dạng
khác nhau. Nhưng mà máy móc nó khác
chúng ta nó không phải như vậy. Máy móc
về bản chất ấy nó chỉ hiểu mỗi cái mã
nhị phân là 0 với 1 thôi đúng không? máy
móc hay mô hình nó chỉ hiểu mỗi cái mã
nhị vân là 0 với 1 thôi. Thế thì tất
nhiên là chúng ta chúng ta thì chúng ta
sẽ làm việc với các cái ngôn ngữ lập
trình bậc cao ví dụ như là Python chẳng
hạn thì chúng ta cũng không đến mức là
chúng ta phải chúng ta phải chúng ta
phải ờ chúng ta phải mã hóa nó th tức là
không đến mức chúng ta phải mã hóa mọi
thứ về 0 với 1 nhưng mà chí ít là chúng
ta cũng phải đưa rượu về dạng số thì mày
nó mới hiểu được đúng không? Thì nếu mà
trong cái rượu ban đầu chúng ta nó có
những cái đặc trưng mà nó không phải
dạng số chẳng hạn thì chúng ta phải t
cách chúng ta số hóa nó chúng ta đưa nó
về dạng số đúng không? Đấy là một cái.
Cái thứ hai nữa là kể cả cái rượu chúng
ta ấy nó có ở dạng số sẵn rồi ấy thì
chúng ta cũng nên đưa nó về cái format,
cái định dạng, cái cái cái giải giá trị
mà đấy thuận lợi cho mô hình. Nó giống
như kiểu này. Ờ các bạn có cái quyển
sách học sách sách sách học tiếng Anh,
sách học I chẳng hạn đúng không? Nhưng
mà không phải cái sách nào nó cũng phù
hợp để các bạn học ngay. Ví dụ giáo viên
có kinh nghiệm thì họ sẽ biết cách làm
sao để họ có thể lọc chắt lọc ra những
cái nội dung nào mà cần thiết, nội dung
quan trọng, nội dung phù hợp để cho bạn
học đúng không? Thì đây nó cũng giống
như vậy. Biết là số thì máy móc nó mô
hình nó hiểu dạng số rồi nhưng mà chúng
ta cũng nên đưa nó về cái dạng nào mà nó
thuận lợi nhất cho quá trình mà mô hình
nó học. Đấy thì đấy là hai cái lý do vì
sao chúng ta phải thực hiện tiền xí dữ
liệu. Thứ nhất là để cho đưa dữ liệu
chúng ta từ cái dạng mà máy nó không
hiểu thành cái dạng máy nó có thể hiểu
và thứ hai là đưa nó về cái dạng nào mà
nó đã thuận lợi cho quá trình chúng ta
huấn luyện mô hình.
Thì sau khi chúng ta tiền sử dữ dượu rồi
chúng ta sẽ có bước tiếp theo là chúng
ta sẽ trực quan hóa dữ liệu. Trực quan
hóa dữ liệu là gì? Trực quan hóa dữ liệu
là chúng ta sẽ dùng những cái bảng biểu,
những cái sơ đồ, những cái figure, những
cái graph, những cái đồ thị để làm sao
chúng ta có thể trực văn hóa cái dữ liệu
chúng ta. Vì sao chúng ta lại cần trực
văn hóa dữ liệu? Thì nó cũng có hai lý
do. Cái lý do đầu tiên ấy là sau này khi
mà các bạn đi làm á các bạn không phải
lúc nào các bạn sẽ cũng sẽ làm việc với
những người mà có cùng cái background
như các bạn. Ví dụ đây chúng ta học
trong lớp này chẳng hạn đúng không? Mọi
người đều học về AI, đều học về dat học
về đều học về machining thì không nói
làm gì. Nhưng mà sao các bạn đi làm các
bạn sẽ làm việc với sếp này, với đồng
nghiệp này, với khách hàng đúng không?
Họ có thể là những người họ sẽ chả có
background gì về dat về machining cả.
Thì bây giờ nếu mà các bạn chứ chỉ đưa
cho họ số má, đưa những cái thống kê
thôi thì khô khan thôi thì họ sẽ rất là
khó để họ có thể hình dung được xem là
cái rượu toan nó như thế nào đúng không?
Thì khi mà các bạn chư c nói dữ liệu,
các bạn dùng những cái bảng biểu hình
ảnh để các bạn có thể thể hiện xem cái
dữ liệu tôi nó có cái tính chất gì thì
nó sẽ dễ hình dung hơn cho cái người đối
diện rất là nhiều đúng không? Đấy là cái
thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa là kể cả các
bạn có làm trong cùng một cái team mà
toàn data scientist với cả toàn maching
engineer đi thì rõ ràng là nhìn hình ảnh
bảng bảng biểu nó vẫn sướng hơn là nhìn
số má đúng không? Nhìn hình bảng biểu nó
vẫn tốt hơn là nhìn nhìn nhìn số nhìn
chữ đúng không? Đấy là cái lý do vì sao
chúng ta phải trực quan hóa dữ liệu.
Chúng ta trực hóa dữ liệu chúng ta sẽ
dùng hình ảnh để chúng ta có thể mô tả
cái rượu ta nó dễ dàng hơn. Được chưa?
Thì các bạn thấy là gì? Các bạn thấy là
từ nãy giờ chúng ta có bốn bước rồi. Từ
thu thập dữ liệu này đến thống kê này
đến tiền xử lý này, đến trực quan hoàn
dữ liệu. Thế thì ngoại trừ cái bước đầu
tiên ra không nói làm gì. Thì bước đầu
tiên là phải làm bắt buộc là phải làm
đầu tiên rồi. Thế thì ba cái bước sau ấy
thống kê tiền xử lý với cả chư vă hóa dữ
liệu ấy thì ba bước này thật ra các bạn
có thể hoàn toàn các bạn có thể trao đổi
thứ tự của chúng hoàn toàn không có vấn
đề gì cả đúng không nhất thiết là cứ
phải thống kê rồi tiền rồi trừ văn hóa
các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn có thể thay
đổi cái thứ tự của chúng nếu các bạn cảm
thấy là thay đổi nó giúp các bạn làm
việc dễ hơn ví dụ với mình thì mình sẽ
luôn đẩy cái bước chừa văn hóa lên đầu
tức là sau khi thuật xong mình sẽ chu
văn hóa luôn xem mặt mũi rượu trông như
nào sau đó mình mới thống kê rồi mình
tiền xử lý tức Tức là giữa ba cái bước
thống kê xử lý về chế văn hóa này nó
không có cái thứ tự cố định mà các bạn
có thể hoàn toàn linh động, các bạn có
thể modify thay đổi chúng tùy theo cái
các bạn thêm cách nào các bạn thấy là nó
giúp cho bạn dễ làm việc nhất thì các
bạn làm được chưa?
Thế bốn bước đầu tiên là liên quan đến
dữ liệu được chưa? Bốn bước đầu tiên là
hoàn toàn liên quan đến dữ liệu chưa có
đạt động gì đến mô hình cả. Đến bước thứ
năm là cái bước mà chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu
chúng ta sẽ làm việc với mô hình. Tức là
gì? Chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu chúng ta sẽ chọn
kỹ thuật toán. chọn cái thuật toán. Thế
thì trong machining ấy có rất nhiều
thuật toán khác nhau. Mỗi thật toán nó
sẽ có những cái ưu nhịn điểm khác nhau.
Thì cái bước này chúng ta sẽ cần phải
làm sao? Chúng ta dựa vào cái dữ liệu
chúng ta dựa vào cái tính chất của dữ
rượu chúng ta sẽ chọn ra một hoặc là một
vài những cái toán phù hợp để chúng ta
thử. Được chưa? Bước này là bước chọn
toán. Bước này thì mình không gọi là xây
dựng gọi là chọn. Tại vì sao? Tại vì bây
giờ ấy tất cả những cái thật toán trong
M người ta đã những người đi trước người
ta đã xây dựng rồi. Người ta đã tích hợp
ở trong các cái thư viện ví dụ như là
cit learn là cái thư viện chúng ta sẽ
học ở trong những buổi sau.
tích hợp sẵn rồi, người ta làm hết rồi,
người ta tối sẵn rồi, các bạn chỉ việc
các bạn lôi ra dùng thôi chứ bây giờ thì
chẳng có ai lại phải đi ngồi tự code lại
những cái thuật toán trong mering làm gì
để làm cái gì cả. Thế nên bước này mình
không gọi là xây dựng, mình chỉ gọi là
chọn thôi. Nó bày ra sẵn rồi, bày ra sẵn
hết rồi. Các bạn chỉ việc các bạn chọn
xem bằng cái nào các bạn thấy là nó nó
phù hợp nhất với cái bộ rượu của chúng
ta. Được chưa? Chọn đội toán này nó sẽ
dựa vào thêm rất nhiều tiêu chí các bạn.
Nó dựa vào ờ tính chất của cái bộ rượu
của bạn. nó dựa vào cái bài toán của các
bạn và nhiều khi nó còn dựa vào cái yêu
cầu của cái bài toán nữa. Tức là yêu cầu
ví dụ chúng ta muốn cái mô hình nó
nhanh, nó nhỏ, nó nhẹ hay là như thế nào
đấy. Được chưa? Thì đấy là cái bước thứ
năm là bước chọn được toán.
Sau đó chúng ta sẽ có hai cái bước mà nó
sẽ xen vào với nhau. Đó là bước model
training và model validation. Tức là à
huấn luyện và huấn luyện và kiểm thử mô
hình. Mình có thể tạm dựng cái
validation gọi là kiểm tử đi. Model
training tức là gì? Model training tức
là nó giống như quá trình các bạn đi học
ấy, nó nhìn quá trình các bạn đi học
hàng ngày ấy đúng không? Các bạn đưa các
bạn nhận bài tập từ cô giáo, các bạn làm
bài rồi các bạn cô giáo sẽ chấm bài đấy,
cô giáo sẽ cho các bạn cái feedback rồi
các bạn sẽ dựa cái feedback để các bạn
có thể cải thiện bản thân ấy đúng không?
Cái đi là như vậy thì đấy là model
training. Thế thì trong quá trình học sẽ
có những cái giai đoạn chúng ta sẽ cần
phải kiểm thử xem là cái mùa chúng ta nó
có đang học đúng hướng hay không đúng
không? Nó giống như kiểu bài thi cuối kỳ
đấy đúng không? Chúng ta cứ học mấy
tháng cho lại thi cuối kỳ một lần đúng
không? Cứ học mấy tháng rồi lại thi cuối
kỳ một lần. Cứ cứ dan sen dan sen như
vậy đúng không? Thì đấy là cái bước
model training và model validation.
Model training dùng để cải thiện mô hình
còn model validation là để theo dõi cái
quá trình huấn luyện xem mô hình có đang
học đúng hướng hay không. Được chưa? Cái
cháu trình này sẽ đan sen vào với nhau
đúng không? Dan vào với nhau chứ nó
không tách rời đúng không? Moding cứ một
đoạn xong lại mod validation cứ liên tục
lên liên tục như vậy. Thế
tất nhiên cái cách mà chúng đang xem
nhau nó còn tùy thuộc vào thuật toán
nữa. Mỗi thuật toán nó sẽ có một kiểu
khác nhau thì trong quá trình chúng ta
học ở vì sao chúng ta sẽ nói kỹ hơn.
Được chưa? Thế thế là model training và
model validation. Sau khi mà chúng ta
hoàn thành quá trình này rồi, tức là sau
khi chúng ta đã hoàn thành xong quá
trình chúng ta huấn luyện mô hình rồi,
chúng ta sẽ có một cái bước chúng ta sẽ
đánh giá mô hình lần cuối cùng đúng
không? Chú đánh đánh giá mô hình lần
cuối cùng. Cái bước đánh giá này nó
giống như kiểu cái bài thi tốt nghiệp
chuộc phổ thông ấy đúng không? Tức là
gì? Sau khi chúng ta xong xuôi hết rồi,
học hành xong xuôi hết rồi, không còn
học cái gì nữa, không còn cải thiện cái
gì nữa thì chúng ta sẽ đánh giá một cái
mô hình lần cuối trên một cái bộ test là
cái bộ mà mô hình nó chưa từng thấy bao
giờ đúng không? Và cái kết quả đánh giá
mô hình trong bộ test này sẽ là cái thứ
mà chúng ta sẽ đưa vào report, đưa vào
báo cáo để show ra cho khách hàng, show
ra cho sếp chẳng hạn, đúng không? Thì
đấy là cái bước model testing. Thì sau
khi mà các bạn xong cái bước model
testing rồi các bạn sẽ bắt đầu các bạn
sẽ triển khai cái mô hình trong thực tế.
triển khai mô hình trong tự tế thì nó
lại cũng có môn hình vạn trạng nó sẽ có
rất nhiều nó sẽ có rất nhiều kiểu khác
nhau. Sẽ có rất nhiều kiểu khác nhau.
Ví dụ cái kiểu người ta sẽ hay làm nhất
là kiểu người ta sẽ triển khai theo kiểu
là server client. Tức là gì? Các bạn sẽ
thuê một cái server, thuê một cái server
ví dụ của một cái ông lớn. Ví dụ như là
các bạn thuê AWS của Amazon hoặc các bạn
thuê ờ Microsoft Azure của Microsoft và
các bạn thuê Google Cloud của Google
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy, các bạn sẽ
thuê một cái nền tảng server như vậy từ
một cái ông lớn ở đấy. Xong các bạn sẽ
chạy cái mô hình này trên server đấy.
Sau đó từ phía khách hàng họ sẽ là
client, họ sẽ chỉ là sao? Họ sẽ họ sẽ họ
sẽ họ sẽ gửi một cái họ sẽ gửi một cái
request họ sẽ gửi một cái request đến
cái server đấy. Họ gửi một cái request
server đấy. Ví dụ cái server các bạn
chạy cái mô hình để dưn giá giá nhà đi
đúng không? Thì bây giờ ở phía họ sẽ
điền thông tin về diện tích này, số tầng
này, vị trí này, có sổ đỏ hay không này,
ờ ở phố nào, ở quận nào, ví dụ như vậy
điền vào sau đó nó sẽ gửi đến cái server
thì cái server nó sẽ cái thông tin đấy
nó sẽ được gửi cho cái mô hình, mô hình
nó sẽ nhận cái input đấy, nó đưa ra dự
đoán. Sau khi dự đoán sẽ được trả ngược
lại phía client, ở phía client chúng ta
sẽ hiển thị lại cái câu trả lời của
server. Đấy, cái kiểu kiểu như vậy thì
đây cách mà cơ bản nhất. Thế ngoài ra
thì bạn nào sau các bạn đi show vào cái
bảng deep learning giống như cái mảng
mình đang làm hiện tại ấy thì chúng ta
sẽ còn có nhiều kiểu triển khác. Ví dụ
là người ta sẽ triển khai cái mô hình
cái cái cái cái mô hình AI này ở trong
cái thiết bị của người dùng. Thường là
những cái thiết bị biên hay người ta gọi
là device. Thiết bị biên là cái gì?
Thiết bị biên là những cái thiết bị mà
nó có những cái mini PC. Mini PC t những
cái thiết bị nó giống như PC mà nó rất
là bé. Nó nó rất là bé. Nó rất là bé.
Tức là nó cũng có phần cứng giống như
một cái PG thật nhưng mà nó rất là bé.
nó có thể nó phù hợp với việc là triển
khai trong thực tế. Đấy ví dụ là ví dụ
thông thường cái minipc rất là phổ biến
đó là cái dòng
device của Nvidia chẳng hạn. Các bạn
nhìn này. Đây là những cái mini PC như
mình vừa mới nói này. Nó rất là bé thôi
nhưng mà chức năng của nó thì không khác
gì một cái mini. Nó không khác gì một
cái một cái một cái PC bình thường. Một
cái PC bình thường có cái gì đây? Con
này nó cũng y chang. Ví dụ đây nhá các
bạn nhìn nhá. Ví dụ đây là con Jesson
Nano nhá. Đây là cái con bé nhất trong
cái dòng sản phẩm Jesson device của
Nvidia. Thì các bạn nhá, nó cũng có quạt
này, nó cũng có chip ở dưới này, nó cũng
có mainbot này, nó cũng có cái chỗ để
các bạn cắm ừ các bạn cắm cắm thẻ nhớ
vào này, cắm cắm dây cắm dây mạng vào
này, đúng không? Cắm USB vào đây, cổng
HDMI cũng có này, cổng cắm nguồn có đủ
hết cả, chả thiếu cái gì cả. Chẳng qua
là nó bé thôi, chẳng qua là nó bé thôi,
đúng không? Đấy, thì đấy là cái cách mà
người ta cũng hay triển khai. Ví dụ như
công ty mình hiện tại bọn mình cũng sẽ
làm như thế. Mình sẽ có một cái thiết bị
như này này
nhá.
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Bọn mình có những
cái camera này. Tức là gì? Camera này nó
dùng để nó thu hình ảnh. Thu hình ảnh
xong bên trong nó cũng sẽ có cái phần
cứng. Tức là nó như một cái PC ở bên
trong này nó đủ mọi thứ luôn. Chip chiếc
GPU, CPU, TPU đủ hết cả. RAM đủ các thứ
đủ hết. Thế mà khi mà thu hình ảnh vào
đây cái cái camera mình cái phần cứng ở
trong nó sẽ xử lý hình ảnh luôn. Nó sẽ
làm mọi thứ trong đấy luôn. Thì đây là
kiểu người ta gọi là device các cái
thiết bị biên
đấy. Các cái thiết bị biên. Thiết bị
biên là thiết bị nó nó triển khai trong
thực tế. Tức là PC của mình thì ngồi ở
nhà đúng không? Thì còn cái thiết bị này
là nó ở luôn cái hiện trường mà chúng ta
thu dữ liệu vào ấy. Đấy thì nó sẽ có cái
kiểu như vậy. Thì khi mà nói về model
diplom thì nó còn nó còn nó còn rất rất
nhiều những cái thứ khác nữa. Nó liên
quan đến cái việc là làm sao để các bạn
có thể thu nhỏ mô hình, các bạn có thể
tối ưu hóa tài nguyên tính toán. Còn rất
rất nhiều cái thứ khác nữa. Thế thì
trong quá trình mình trong quá trình đi
làm ấy thì hai cái bước mà tốn nhiều
theo nhất sẽ là bước đầu với bước cuối.
Hai bước này là hai bước sẽ luôn luôn
tốn nhiều thời gian nhất. Cái bước đầu
nó tốn thời gian tại vì là dữ liệu nó
không tự nhiên nó có đúng không? Nó phải
có một ai đấy người ta đi thu thập ta
ngồi đánh nhãn đúng không? Bước cuối nó
khó ở chỗ là mỗi một khách hàng nó triển
khai thì các bạn sẽ mỗi một khách hàng
triển khai thì các bạn sẽ có những cái ờ
nó sẽ có những cái họ sẽ dụng những cái
thiết bị khác nhau. Có ông dùng thiết bị
của Nvidia, có ông dùng thiết bị của
Google, có ông dùng thiết bị của Apple.
Thì mỗi một cái ông lớn này thì các bạn
muốn triển khai các bạn sẽ phải làm kiểu
khác nhau đúng không? Trừ khi các bạn
triển khai trên server thì không nói là
làm gì nhưng mà các bạn muốn triển khai
trên tại thiết bị biên ấy thì mỗi một
thiết bị nó lại có kiểu triển khai khác
nhau. Đấy
thì đấy là một cái pipeline hoàn chỉnh.
Thường trong quá trình các bạn đi học
các bạn sẽ không bao giờ phải lo bước
đầu với bước cuối. Các bạn đi học thì
thường các bạn ví dụ là dữ liệu sẽ có
sẵn nhá đúng không? Sau thì thầy sẽ yêu
cầu các bạn sử dụng cái mô hình gì đấy.
Sau các bạn làm xong các bạn ra một cái
mô hình có kết quả thầy tính ra được
Aquac bằng 90% xong cho các bạn điểm
xong thầy về nhà thầy cho về nhà trò
cũng chả quan tâm là cái mô hình này sau
này được dùng như thế nào. Nhưng mà khi
mà các bạn đi làm thì đấy mới chỉ là một
nửa vấn đề thôi. Làm sao các bạn phải
triển khai trong thực tế làm sao thì
khách hàng có thể dùng được là một
chuyện khác. Đấy khi các bạn đi học
người ta chỉ có tâm độ chính xác. Tức là
cái mô hình dự là nó càng chính xác thì
càng tốt. Nhưng mà sau này các bạn đi
làm các bạn sẽ lo về những cái thứ như
ví dụ như là tốc độ xử lý này có chạy
được trong thời gian thực hay không,
tiêu tốn tài nguyên như thế nào đúng
không? Mô hình có tốt có đẹp đến mấy nữa
mà nó nặng quá nó to quá nó không triển
khai điện trong thần thực thì nó cũng
chả có ý nghĩa. Tức là sự bạn nó không
triển khai cho khách hàng đáp ứng được
cái yêu cầu về mức độ thời gian chẳng
hạn thì cũng chả có ý nghĩa gì cả. Đó ví
dụ bây giờ mình sử dụng cái mô hình để
nhận diện biển số xe đi để ứng dụng cho
chích file trong giao thông ấy đúng
không? Mô hình mình nhận diện biển số xe
rất là tốt nhưng mà mô hình mình chạy
chậm quá chạy th thực tế nó chỉ một
khung một giây nó chỉ chạy được có hai
khung hình thôi thì nó cũng sẽ không đảm
bảo yêu cầu về thời gian thực ch ta cũng
sẽ không dùng nó được đúng không đây là
một cái machining pipel play hoàn chỉnh
sau các bạn đi làm thì các bạn kiểu gì
các bạn sẽ phải đi qua tất cả những cái
bước này được chưa tất nhiên là những
cái bước ở giữa tức là ngoại trừ bước
đầu với bước cuối như cái bước ở giữa ấy
thì bây giờ các cái thư viện nó làm rất
là sẵn rồi nên các bạn gần như là rất là
nhanh đấy chỉ có bước đầu với bước cuối
là nó mất thời gian nhất thôi thế nhưng
mà khốn nỗi là trên trường các bạn học
thì thường lại bỏ hai cái bước
Ok. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có th mắc gì không?
Có b nào thắc mắc gì không? Any
questions?
Không ai thắc mắc gì thì tiếp nhá.
Rồi các bạn nhìn này,
nếu ta server thì
đúng rồi. Một là các bạn tự đ thật ra
bây giờ ấy thật ra cái back end là cái
khó cái chúng ta làm mô hình cái mà cái
khó cho cái phông thì các bạn dùng các
bạn các bạn dùng close hoặc các bạn dùng
antigravity hoặc là các bạn thậm chí các
bạn dùng chat gravity bổ phát là xong
ngay. Ấ mà mấy hôm tới đ hôm n hôm chúng
ta thực hành xong xong mô hình chúng
mình sẽ thử các bạn cho mình chỉ dùng
chatbt thôi. Yêu cầu nó tạo ra một cái
UI cực kỳ dễ luôn nhá. UI bây giờ cái
buổi ngày nay UI thì nó quá là dễ để nó
làm luôn.
Chúng ta cần một bộ dữ liệu liên quan
đến bài toán của chúng ta. Nếu mà chơi
một cái mô hình tốt thì chúng ta cần một
cái bộ dữ liệu có liên quan đến bài
toán. Muốn xếp một cái mô hình dự giá
nhà thì phải có một cái bộ dữ liệu về
giá nhà. Muốn xếp một cái dữ liệu để một
chên một cái mô hình để nhận diện à biển
số xe thì phải có rất nhiều dữ liệu về
biển số xe đúng không? Chúng ta muốn có
một cái mô hình tốt về cái gì chúng ta
phải có rất nhiều dữ liệu về cái bài
toán đấy đúng không? liên quan đến bài
toán đấy. Thế là xong
rồi. Có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Tiếp nhá.
Thế các bạn nhìn này, chúng ta sẽ chúng
ta sẽ sẽ nói tiếp về dữ liệu nhá. Chúng
ta sẽ nói tiếp về dữ liệu. Đấy các bạn
chú ý nhá. Dữ liệu tốt nó chỉ là cái
bước đầu tiên thôi. Chúng ta sẽ còn rất
nhiều thứ khác nữa. Chúng ta sẽ làm sao
chúng ta xử lý dữ liệu phù hợp này.
Chúng ta chọn mô hình phù hợp. Tức là
mỗi một cái mô hình nó sẽ có những cái
ưu điểm nhược điểm khác nhau. Có những
mô hình nó phù hợp có những cái mô hình
nó phù hợp với cái bộ rượu này. Có những
mô hình nó phù hợp với bộ dữ liệu khác
sẽ không bao giờ có chuyện là một mô
hình nó phù hợp với nó phù hợp với tất
cả mọi bộ dữ liệu. Thì làm sao chúng ta
phải hiểu xem cái bộ dữ liệu chúng ta nó
phù hợp với cái gì. Từ đó chúng ta chọn
cái mô hình phù hợp thì lúc đấy nó mới
có thể tối ưu hóa cái
bộ dữ liệu mà chúng ta mất công nh thu
tu thu tập. Được chưa?
Tiếp này các bạn này. Thế bây giờ chúng
ta sẽ nói về từng cái bước một. Được
chưa? Đầu tiên là cái bước thống kê.
Thống kê thì nó sẽ có vô số cái kiểu
thống kê khác nhau nhưng các bạn có thể
hiểu hiểu một cách đơn giản là gì? Thống
kê chúng ta sẽ có thể làm một vài cái
thống kê nó rất là cơ bản thôi. Ví dụ là
cái bộ dượu rượu dọ bảng đi đúng không?
Thì chúng ta xem là dựa dọ bảng chúng ta
nó có bao nhiêu hàng, nó có bao nhiêu
cột đúng không? Kiểu dữ liệu của từng
cột là gì? Được chưa? Kiểu dữ liệu của
từng cột là gì?
Kiểu rượu của từng cột là gì đúng không?
Chúng ta xem là chúng ta có cái ô nào có
những cái ô nó bị khuyết dữ liệu hay
không đúng không? Xem là có những cái
hàng nào nó bị trùm lập với nhau hay
không đúng không? Chúng ta xem là ví dụ
nếu mà nó là bài toán phân loại bài toán
classification chúng ta sẽ xem rằng là
cái tỉ lệ số lượng sample giữa các cái
class nó có bị lệch hay không? Có ông
nào bị ít quá ông nào nhiều quá hay
không đúng không? Thế ngoài ra thì chúng
ta có thể có một vài những cái thống kê
chuyên sâu hơn ví dụ như là tính giá trị
nhỏ nhất giá trị lớn nhất đúng không? Kỳ
vọng phương sai, độ lệnh chuẩn đúng
không? Marian với quan sai. Marian quan
sai tiếng Việt là cái gì các bạn? Merian
về quan trai tiếng Việt là cái gì?
Median tiếng Việt là gì? Quan sai tiếng
Việt là gì?
>> Phạch là trung vị và phân
>> trung vị. Đúng rồi. Trung vị. Quan sai
này gọi là cái gì?
Quan trai gọi là cái gì các bạn?
Quan trai gọi là
median là trung vị. Đúng rồi. Quan trai
gọi là cái gì? Tiếng Việt mình gọi là
cái gì?
Đúng rồi. Tứ phân vị khác. Có bạn nào
định nghĩa mình xem là
trúc vị tìm ra như nào? Tứ phân vị tìm
ra như nào?
Làm sao tôi có một cái bộ rượu ví dụ là
tôi có một cái dữ liệu về diện tích đúng
không? Ví dụ tôi có một cái cột là về
square feit là về diện tích căn nhà đúng
không? Làm sao để tôi có thể tìm được
trung vị của nó. Bây giờ
tôi có một cái bộ dữ liệu về 100 1000
căn nhà. Mỗi căn nhà tôi đều có thông
những cái thông tin về diện tích này, số
tầng này, số phòng ngủ này, bây giờ giá
đúng không? Thế bây giờ riêng với cái
cột là diện tích đi thì bây giờ tôi muốn
tôi muốn tìm ra cái
trung vị của cái cột square feet này tôi
tìm như nào bây giờ?
Làm sao mình tìm ra chung bị nó bây giờ?
Chỗ này thì em nghĩ là sẽ sắp xếp dữ
liệu từ nhỏ đến lớn xong lấy
điểm và giữa điểm ở giữa nó sẽ là như
điền. Còn quan thì là nó là điểm 1/4 của
sau khi sắp xếp.
>> Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Chính xác. Đúng rồi.
Đúng rồi.
Trung vị là như nào? Là chúng ta sẽ phải
đầu tiên chúng ta phải sắp xếp dữ liệu
theo thứ tự bé đến lớn đúng không? Ví dụ
cái square feet này các bạn có 1000 giá
trị đúng không? Các bạn phải sắp xếp
chúng từ bé đến lớn. Sa các bạn lấy đúng
cái phần tử ở giữa ấ thì nó sẽ là nó sẽ
là trung vị. Đây này
nhá.
Đây đúng không? Giả sử nhá mình sẽ giá
trị từ bé đến lớn đúng không? Ví dụ là
nhả bé nhất là 10 m² thì có vài căn 10
đi 11 12 vân vân à 30 50 31 vân đúng
không? 60 60 ví dụ như vậy đúng không?
có 1000 ngăn như vậy thì bây giờ các bạn
sẽ lấy ra cái giá trị ở giữa. Giá trị ở
giữa nó sẽ có hai trường hợp. Một là nếu
mà số lượng phần tử nó là số lẻ thì các
bạn sẽ luôn có một cái số ở giữa. Thì
cái số này nó chính là trung vị. Còn nếu
mà số lượng phần tử nó là số chẵn ấy thì
các bạn sẽ có hai phần tử ở giữa. Thì
lúc này trung vị sẽ là tổng trung bình
cộng của hai ông này sẽ cộng và chia đôi
đúng không? Ra ví dụ là 30,5 ví dụ như
vậy. Được chưa? Đây là trung vị, đây
chính là median.
Được chưa? Đây là median. Thế thế bây
giờ ấy từ phần tử min đến trung vị các
bạn lấy đúng phần tử ở giữa thì cái này
người ta đ là first quanti.
Và tương tự như vậy từ median với cả đến
max chúng ta lấy một phần tử ở đây nữa
là th quanti.
Th
được chưa? Thế thì bây giờ ba phần tử là
first quanti. Median người ta gọi là
second quanti. Hai cái tên khác nhau.
Tên nào cũng được. First qu time second
quant và time. Đây là ba cái điểm nó sẽ
chia rượu các bạn. ta đánh bốn phần bằng
nhau, bằng nhau về mặt số lượng phần tử
sau khi chúng ta đã sắp xếp rồi đúng
không? Thì đây ba cái điểm này người ta
gọi là tứ phân vị. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó
chia ruệ bạn ra thành bốn phần bằng nhau
về mặt số lượng. Được chưa? Hệ đấy là
median. Median là trung vị và tứ vân vị
được chưa?
Đọc quan trai
bạn nào ngày xưa bạn học muốn sáu suất
thống kê kiểu gì bạn học cái này rồi
đúng không? Sáu suất thống kê cũng có
cái đúng không? Trung bình trung vị có
đủ cả đúng không? Thế interquant rin là
cái gì? là cái khoảng cách từ cái first
quant đến first quanti. Đấy, khoảng cách
từ Q1 đến Q3 đấy. Lấy Q3 - Q1 là các bạn
sẽ ra được cái interi range này hoặc ta
tức là IQR này đúng không? Ngoài ra
chúng ta sẽ phải đánh giá xem là cái
rượu rõ là nó có nó có outlier hay
không. Outler là cái gì? Outler là những
cái điểm rượu nó khác biệt với những cái
điểm rượu còn lại. Ví dụ các bạn thấy là
công ty lương ông nào cũng toàn 10 12
triệu thì lò ra một ông lương 100 triệu
chẳng hạn thì ông đấy là outayer đúng
không? Giá nhà căn nào nó cũng vài tỷ
thì lòi ra một căn giá có 100 triệu
chẳng hạn thì căn đấy là outayer đúng
không? Thường thông thường cái outayer
là những thứ nó sẽ khiến cho cái mô hình
nó bị nó sẽ thu nó sẽ làm nó sẽ làm nó
sẽ làm lệch cái sự chú ý của mô hình về
nó. Chúng ta thường chúng ta sẽ thông
thường chúng ta sẽ có cái xu hướng người
ta muốn sẽ muốn loại bỏ những cái outer
này đúng không? Chúng chúng ta sẽ muốn
loại bỏ tại vì chúng ta muốn là mô hình
chúng ta nó phải tập trung vào những cái
dữ liệu phổ thông phổ biến chứ chúng ta
không muốn nó tập trung vào một hai cái
điểm dữ liệu khác thường đúng không? Thế
do đó thì thường ta sẽ xuố hướng loại bỏ
out layer. Thế nhưng mà không phải lúc
nào chúng ta cũng sẽ cần phải loại bỏ
outlayer đúng không? Tí nữa khi chúng ta
nói về cái outay này, chúng ta sẽ sẽ nói
cái trường hợp là khi nào chúng ta chúng
ta chúng ta phải loại bỏ và khi nào thì
không nhá. Đây là cái bước mà bước đầu
tiên sau khi chúng ta thu xong dữ liệu.
Tức là chúng ta sẽ làm một cái thống kê.
Được chưa? Thống kê.
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có nào có hỏi không?
Anh em hỏi một câu.
>> Ừ em hỏi đi. Em hỏi đi. Em hỏi đi.
>> Anh em hỏi anh em hỏi em hỏi là cái chỗ
ví dụ data của mình nó có outline
outliner ấy thầy thì
mình nên phát hiện nó ở bước data
visualiz
>> xem nó ở bước nào?
>> Thông thường ở data visual mình sẽ chưa
nhìn ra được ngay nữa. Tức là tức là
cũng cũng có thể mình cũng có thể mình
sẽ nhìn ra được ngay nhưng mà thường
mình có thể sử thống kê. Sự thống kê. Ví
dụ là người ta thường người ta sẽ sử
dụng ví dụ là theo cái sử dụng theo phân
phối chuẩn ấy, tức là cái điểm dữ liệu
nào mà nó nằm ngoài ba lần đồ lệch chuẩn
so với kỳ vọng ấy là người ta sẽ loại bỏ
ra đúng không? Đấy thường người ta có
thể dùng thống kê thì mình sẽ biết được
chứ còn nhìn ra chúng ta nhìn thì cũng
được nhưng mà không phải lúc nào nó cũng
dễ dàng nhất là khi chúng ta có nhiều dữ
liệu quá thì không phải lúc nào cái
outer nó cũng sẽ hiện ra ch chúng cho
chúng ta xem và thứ hai nữa là thường dữ
liệu ra nó sẽ có rất là nhiều chiều rất
là nhiều chiều thì khi mà chúng ta muốn
trườn văn hóa chúng ta thường chúng ta
sẽ phải giảm chiều dữ liệu mà khi giảm
chiều rồi thì có thể là cái al nó sẽ khó
nhìn hơn đấy.
Rồi có bắt nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Tiếp nhá. Với cả một cái nữa là gì? Trực
quân hóa có thể giúp chúng ta nhìn ra
xem là có outlet hay không. Nhưng mà
muốn bốc nó ra thì vẫn phải dùng qua
thống kê đúng không? Tại vì ví dụ nhìn
trong cái ảnh đấy thì bây giờ làm sao mà
lôi nó ra được bây giờ. Thì loanh quanh
kiểu gì cũng phải qua thống kê đúng
không? Chứ nhìn cái ảnh mới gọi có 1000
sle các bạn thấy một ông nó vọt hẳn lên.
Thế bây giờ làm sao để lấy ông đấy ra
bây giờ đúng không? Thì vẫn phải qua
thống kê chứ.
quay có câu hỏi gì nữa không
tiếp nhá. Đấy, đấy là lý do vì sao mà
thường các bạn học ở đại học ý các bạn
những cái môn Đại Cương các bạn hay có
cái môn sắp suất thống kê là vì như vậy
đấy. Để những lớp như này này. Đó
tiếp nhá. Thì bước tiếp theo chúng ta sẽ
làm việc liên quan đến tiền xử lý dữ
liệu. Tiền xử lý dữ liệu thì có rất là
nhiều bước. Thì ví dụ là cái bước đầu
tiên là gì? Là chúng ta sẽ phải xử lý
những cái ô nào nó bị khuyết đúng không?
Xử lý những cái người ta gọi là missing
value đúng không? Xử lý missing value.
Thì ví dụ đây đây là một cái bộ dữ liệu
liên quan đến giá nhà được chưa? Như vẫn
như vậy, chúng ta vẫn có những cái đặc
trưng như là diện tích này, số tầng này,
vị trí này và chúng ta có một cái cột là
về giá của căn nhà. Được chưa? Giá của
căn nhà. Đấy. Thế bây gi các bạn cho
mình hỏi nhá. Giả sử đây các bạn thấy là
chúng ta có hai cái ô bị khuyết như này,
đúng không? Theo các bạn bây giờ khi
chúng ta gặp bộ rượu bị khuyết ấy, chúng
ta có cách xử lý nào? Khi chúng ta gặp
một cái bộ rượu mà có những cái ô nó bị
khuyết ấy, chúng ta có những cách xử lý
nào?
Chúng gặp dữ liệu có những cái ô khuyết.
Như vậy chúng ta xử lý như thế như nào
bây giờ?
Rượu chúng ta có 1000 hàng đi chúng ta
sẽ có một vài ô thi thoảng nó bị khuyết
một ô phát. Thì v chúng ta xử lý nào?
Bây giờ nếu để nguyên như vậy mà đưa vào
mô hình kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ lỗi. Đưa vào
mô hình dữ liệu bị khuyết này kiểu gì nó
cũng sẽ lỗi. Chúng ta sẽ phải xử lý
trước.
Có những cách nào chúng ta xử lý các
bạn? Có những cách nào xử lý? Các bạn
liệt kê mình tất cả những cách có thể có
không nào? Xóa là một cách chính xác.
Xóa luôn cái hàng đấy là một cách đúng
không? Thông thường nhá, thông thường
thì thường luật bất thành văn tức là nếu
mà tổng số lượng hàng mà có những cái ô
bị khuyết ấy nó dưới 5% thì các bạn có
thể loại bỏ luôn cái hàng này đi đúng
không? Loại bỏ luôn cái hàng này đi.
Đấy. Nhưng mà nếu mà nhiều trên 5 nếu mà
những cái ô những cái hàng có ô bị
khuyết ấy mà nó nhiều trên 5% ấy chúng
ta thì chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ thường
chúng ta sẽ không loại bỏ. Tại vì là nếu
mà loại bỏ đi thì rượu còn mấy đâu đúng
không? Nếu mà nó có nhiều hàng nó bị
khuyết quá các bạn loại bỏ đi nó chả còn
mấy cả nó chả còn mấy. Thế
thì trong trường hợp chúng ta không loại
bỏ được chúng ta sẽ phả phải cách chúng
ta sẽ điền vào đúng không? Như vậy các
bạn bảo là imputation đấy đúng không?
Như vậy bạn bạn Khoa Bảo là imputation.
Imputation chính là chúng ta phải điền
vào đấy đúng không? Điền vào thì nó lại
có hai kiểu đúng không? Thường nó sẽ có
hai kiểu phổ biến. Một là chúng ta điền
vào trong cái ô dạng số và hai là chúng
ta điền vào trong những cái ô dạng
categorical đúng không? Ví dụ điền vào
dạng số cái cột square feet này dạng số
thì các bạn sẽ có hai các bạn sẽ có các
bạn sẽ có một vài cách đúng không? Điền
vào dạng số thì các bạn có thể điền vào
giá trị trung bình đúng không? Hoặc là
trung bình hoặc là hoặc là gì các bạn?
Cái ô này này cái ô mà này cái ô này
hoặc là các bạn điền vào trung bình hay
các bạn điền bằng cái gì?
Hoặc là trung bình hoặc là cái gì
hoặc là trung vị. Đúng rồi. Trung bình
trung vị. Theo các bạn trung bình trung
vị điền bằng cái nào tốt hơn?
Theo các bạn trung bình và trung vị đi
bằng cái nào tốt hơn?
Thông thường chúng ta nghe trung bình
thì có vẻ nghe phổ thông hơn đúng không?
Nhưng mà đúng rồi, điền vào đây thông
thường các bạn điền bằng trung vị nó sẽ
tốt hơn. Vì sao điền bằng trung vị nó
lại tốt hơn là trung bình? Mặc dù trung
bình nó phổ biến hơn đúng không? Người
ngoài ngành người ta chả biết gì về sá
tống kê người ta biết trung bình là cái
gì nhưng trung vị không phải ai cũng
biết. Vì sao điền trung vị lại tốt hơn
là trung bình?
Vì sao điền trung vị lại tốt hơn điền
trung bình?
Vì sao dùng trung vị ở đây lại tốt hơn
là trung bình?
Trung bình thường số phận âm không phải
như vậy. Số tôi vẫn chả vấn đề gì cả.
Mấy phả mới phải trả vấn đề. Đúng rồi.
Tránh ảnh hưởng của outlayer. Đúng rồi.
Lý do vì sao người ta dùng trung vị là
gần như là khi các bạn dùng trung vị thì
gần như các bạn sẽ miễn nhiễm với
outlayer đúng không? Tại vì outlayer cái
cái xác suất mà nó rơi vào cái dị trung
bị cực kỳ hiếm luôn đúng không? Thế còn
nếu các bạn dùng trung bình thìer nó sẽ
tham gia vào quá trình tính cái dị trung
bình đấy nó sẽ nó sẽ gây ảnh hưởng tiêu
cực đến giá trị trung bình các bạn tính
ra đúng không? Thế ở đây người ta sẽ
thường xu hướng người ta dùng trung vị
nhiều hơn là trung bình được chưa?
Thế còn về những cái cột về cả dạng
categorical như là location chúng ta sẽ
dùng mode. Mode là cái giá trị xuất hiện
nhiều nhất đấy đúng không? Mean median
tức cả mode là ba cái thống kê mà đều
bắt đầu bằng chữ m đúng không? Mode thì
ta sẽ dùng cho cái location này chưa?
Mode đấy.
Mình hỏi các bạn nhá. Mình hỏi các bạn
này. Nếu cái ô bị khuyết ấy chẳng may nó
rơi vào đúng cái cột target tức là nó
rơi vào cái cột price này đúng không?
Chúng x cái mô hình dự giá nhà đúng
không? Thì cái cột price chính là cái
target đúng không? Nếu cái ô bị khuyết ý
nó rơi vào cột price này thì các bạn làm
như nào?
Nếu cái ô bị khuyết bị rơi vào cột price
này thì bạn làm thế nào?
Điền vào một số đã xác định từ trước.
Nếu ô bị khuyết rơi vào cột price này
các bạn làm thế nào? Một bạn bảo là điền
vào một số đã xác định từ trước. Số xác
định trước là số nào? 1 tỷ hay 2 tỷ hay
3 tỷ? Bỏ hoặc để trung bình lấy giá trị
gần nhất. Thế nào gọi là gần nhất? Thế
nào gọi là giá trị gần nhất? Căn cứ vào
đâu để biết đâu là đâu là giá trị gần
nhất?
Một bạn bảo là không nên dùng nên bỏ
hàng đó.
Các bạn khác thì sao?
Có hai bạn bảo là nên bỏ.
Vì sao lại nên bỏ các bạn? Sao các bạn
lại nghĩ là nên bỏ?
Vì sao bạn nghe
fit square giống nhau thì price giống
không? Rồi có từng kia feature thì bây
giờ biết giống giống theo cái gì bây giờ
giống theo feature squarey square
feature hay là hay square feet hay là
giống theo no flaw hay là giống theo
location bây giờ có nhiều này biết giống
là giống cái nào bây giờ
là mình học sai ấy vì sao lại học sai
thì rộng vẫn là điền thôi mà vừa nãy
mình cũng điền thôi mà square feet với
cả location mình cũng điền thôi mà
à đúng rồi nó là nhãn đúng rồi nhãn
không không điền được đúng không input
đầu vào thì có thể điền được nhưng mà
cái output đầu ra thì không điền được.
Nó là cái ground true, nó là giá trị
thực tế không điền được đúng không?
Ground true hay là label thì không được
phép điền. Nó giống như kiểu cái đáp án
của bài của bài tập đấy đúng không? Đáp
án làm sao mà các bạn tự điền được. Đáp
án là phải có sẵn đúng không? Đáp án là
phải có sẵn làm sao mà làm sao mà tự
ngồi điền được đúng không? Nếu mà cái
giá trị bị khuyết ấ vào cái cột price
các bạn chỉ có bỏ cái hàng đi thôi.
Không tự điền được đúng không? Không tự
điền được. Điền đâu thì điền chứ không
điền cái cái tăng ít được đúng không?
Rồi, đấy là về xử lý các cái ô bị khuyết
đúng không? Xử lý các ô bị khuyết. Thế
thế tiếp theo này nó có một kiểu nữa là
gì? Là thi thoảng cái bộ dữ liệu do quá
trình nhập liệu hay là gì đấy trong do
thu thập dữ liệu nó sẽ có những cái ô nó
bị nó sẽ không phải những ô xin các bạn,
nó sẽ có những cái hàng nó bị nó bị
trùng lặp. Nó bị trùng lặp đây ví dụ đây
này đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải loại bỏ
chúng đúng không? Trùng lập chúng ta nên
loại bỏ đúng không? Nên loại bỏ thì
chúng giống hệt nhau mà ch giữ nhiều làm
gì đâu đúng không?
Được chưa? Duplicate thì mình sẽ loại bỏ
bớt đi. Được chưa? Thế thế tiếp theo
chúng ta sẽ có một cái nữa là chúng ta
liên quan đến a
gì? Liên quan đến format của dữ liệu.
Format của dữ liệu tức là gì? Tức là các
bạn nhìn này. Ví dụ chúng ta có cái cột
về thời gian đúng không? Thì thời gian
nó sẽ phải đồng nhất với nhau. Ví dụ là
ngày tháng năm hoặc là năm tháng ngay
đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải đống nhất
với nhau. Được chưa? Đấ dụ ngày đến
tháng rồi đến năm hoặc là năm rồi đến
tháng đến ngày phải đồng nhất với nhau
chứ không được kiểu là lộn xộn với nhau.
Nếu lộn xộn chúng ta phải đưa về cùng
một cái dạng đúng không? Hoặc là về tiền
tệ đúng không? Cái dấu đô la một là đi
trước hay là đi sau chứ không thể nào có
chỗ đi trước chỗ đi sau được đúng không?
Chúng ta phải đưa hết về một dạng. Được
chưa?
Về thời gian ấy, về thời gian thì trong
data s ấy nó có rất nhiều cái format
khác nhau. Nó sẽ có cái dạng là ví dụ
như là ngày tháng năm nó sẽ có hai kiểu
nhá là ngày đi trước với cả năm đi trước
đúng không? Ngày đi trước sẽ là ngày
tháng năm còn năm đi trước là 5 tháng
ngày. Được chưa? Rồi nó có thể thêm cả
giờ phút giây rồi ngày tháng 5 giờ phút
giây nó có rất nhiều format khác nhau.
Đấy cái hôm chúng ta học về bài toán
time c forcasting ý chúng ta sẽ còn xem
chúng ta sẽ còn những cái có những cái
định dạng gì nữa. Đấy
về giá tiền thì cũng như vậy thôi. Dấu
đô la dấu euro, dấu giống dấu yên gì đấy
chúng phải đồng đảm bản đồng nhất với
nhau. Thế nhưng mà thông thường trong
quá trình chúng ta xử lý dong này, chúng
ta sẽ bỏ luôn cái ký tự đi đúng không?
Ký tự đô la ấy đúng không? Chúng ta bỏ
hết nó đi đúng không? Nếu mà tất cả giá
trị đấy nó đều cùng một đơn vị đo thì
chúng ta sẽ bỏ hết nó đi. Còn nếu mà đơn
vị đo khác nhau ví dụ ông thì đô la, ông
thì oil chúng ta sẽ convert sang một cái
giá trị chung chung nào đấy. Được chưa?
Đấy.
Tiếp này. Tiếp theo là những cái
outlayer đúng không? Outler thì thông
thường thông thường người ta hay có cái
xu hướng người ta loại bỏ outlayer tại
vì outlayer nó là cái thứ nó khiến Vì
sao người ta lại muốn lại bỏ outlayer?
Tại vì outlayer nó là cái thứ nó sẽ thu
hút cái sự tập trung của mô hình. Vì sao
lại thu hút? Tại vì nó đ tạo ra cái size
số lớn. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Những cái điểm
màu xanh này, những cái điểm bình thường
này đúng không? Size số nó rất là bé.
Nhưng cái outer này nó sẽ tạo ra cái
size số rất là lớn. Mà size số mà lớn ấy
thì trong quá trình chúng ta tối ưu hóa
mô hình thì mô hình sẽ xuống nó sẽ làm
sao? Nó phải nó sẽ phải tập trung để nó
làm giảm thiểu sai số đúng không? Ông
nào làm sai số lớn thì mô hình sẽ phải
tập trung vào ông đấy nhiều hơn. Tức là
cái mô hình chúng ta là cái đường màu
xanh này ấy nó sẽ có xu hướng là nó sẽ
tập trung vào cái outer này hơn so với
những cái điểm bình thường này đúng
không? mà chúng ta sẽ sử dụng mô hình,
chúng ta muốn cái mô hình chúng ta nó sẽ
hoạt động tốt với cái dữ liệu tổng quát,
cái dữ liệu mà thường gặp chứ chúng ta
không muốn nó làm việc tốt với chỉ với
một cái hai cây riêng biệt như này đúng
không? Thế thì khi mà có cái outer này
thông thường nó sẽ khiến cho cái mô hình
nó sẽ phải tập trung hơn cái outlay này
và nó sẽ khiến cho cái performance của
cái mô hình với những cái rượu khác nó
bị ảnh hưởng đi đúng không? Thì đấy là
lý do vì sao mà người ta sẽ cần phải
thường người ta có cái xu hướng ta muốn
loại bỏ out layer. Tuy nhiên không phải
lúc nào cũng như vậy còn tùy bài toán.
Ví dụ các bạn muốn sử dụng cái mô hình
để phân loại người bị ung thư với người
bình thường đi đúng không? Thì những cái
người bị ung thư ấy là những người mà nó
sẽ có rất là ít sample đúng không? Cái
class người bị ung thư nó rất là ít
sample thì vô tình có thể những cái
sample của các người bị ung thư ấy nó sẽ
khác biệt rất là nhiều với những cái
sample của người bình thường. Thế nên là
ấy dưới góc nhìn của dữ liệu thì những
người bị ung thư chính là out layer. Thế
nhưng mà bây giờ chúng ta đang muốn xây
dựng mô hình phân loại người ung thư với
người khỏe mạnh mà bây giờ cứ gặp ông
nào ung thư các bạn lại bỏ hết đi thì
còn gì để mà học nữa đúng không? Thế nên
là cái việc loại bỏ out này không phải
lúc nào chúng ta loại bỏ. Chúng phải xem
cái bài toán đấy nó có c nó đúng có thực
sự cần loại bỏ out hay không đúng không?
Ví dụ các bạn sử dụng mô hình dự ấn giá
nhà chẳng hạn thì các bạn loại bỏ được
tại vì bây giờ tự nhiên căn nào cũng vài
tỷ thì lại tên này sẽ có một căn nó chỉ
có 100 triệu thôi đúng không? Thì căn
này nó là căn nó rất là khác biệt và
trong thực tế thì gần như các bạn sẽ
không gặp cái căn này bao giờ thì mình
sẽ loại bỏ đi để tránh cái việc là mô
hình nó tập trung quá nhiều và cái căn
nhà này nó lại làm ảnh hưởng đến
performance của mô hình trên những căn
nhà khác đúng không? Đấy nên là outer là
cái thứ mà không phải lúc nào cũng loại
bỏ và chúng ta phải xem cái bài toán đấy
về alevel nó có vai trò gì hay không
đúng không? Nếu nó sự nó là thứ dư thừa
thì mình loại bỏ đi. Còn nếu nó là cái
nhân tố quan trọng chúng ta phải thì
chúng ta phải giữ nó lại đúng không? Cái
đấy là cái bước chúng ta loại bỏ out
layer đúng không?
Rồi các bạn đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì
không?
Thay vì loại bỏ al ra thì ta dùng min
square root để hạn chế sử dụng chung của
al
mình dùng min square root. min square
hay là min absolute thì nếu mà mình dùng
min square root ấy thì mô hình nó còn
tập trung nhiều hơn vào a layer. Nếu
mình dùng min square thì mô hình thậm
chí nó còn tập trung nhiều hơn vào aler.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì cái xe số nó bị bình
phương lên đúng không? Để bậc một thì
cái ảnh hưởng của al nó còn ít chứ các
bạn để bình phương lên nó còn nhiều nữa
đúng không? Bình phương cái xố lên để
bình thường x nó lớn rồi, bình phương
lên nó còn to nữa thì mô hình sẽ lại
càng phải tập trung vào nó đúng không?
Thì các đúng không?
Minus thì thì bình thường nhưng mà nó
cũng không minus thì nó cũng không có
loại bỏ cái ảnh hưởng của layer.
Min square nó đã không ảnh hưởng nó
không loại bỏ nó còn nó còn làm cho mình
nó tập trung hơn vào aer đúng không? Còn
min absolute thì nó đâu có cơ chế gì nó
loại bỏ ảnh hưởng của aler đâu đúng
không? Nó size số 10 nó vẫn cứ là 10 chứ
nó đâu có bớt cái gì đâu. Đúng không?
Quay có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
>> Em hỏi một câu đúng không Ừ. Em hỏi đi.
>> Ở cái đoạn trước anh bảo là cái bản ghi
mà nó trùng lặp hoàn toàn thì bỏ đi ấy.
>> Ờ
>> sao mình lại bỏ đi ạ?
>> Tại vì mình không tại vì đưa vào nhiều
dữ liệu giống nhau có để làm gì đâu. Dữ
liệu hoặc là giống nhau có để làm gì
đâu. Đó.
>> Nhưng em tưởng là mỗi một bàn ghi thì nó
sẽ có một cái ID riêng biệt chứ.
>> Đúng. Nhưng đây là v nhưng mà vì tại vì
cái ID lúc nào nó cũng sẽ khác biệt. Thế
nhưng mà cái nội dung ở bên trong nếu mà
chúng giống nhau thì mình sẽ phải loại
bỏ đi đúng không? Tại vì có thể trong
quá trình nhập liệu người ta nhập nhầm
một căn người ta nhập vào hai căn chẳng
người ta nhập vào hai lần chẳng hạn thì
ID khác nhau là chuyện bình thường đúng
không? ID thì bao giờ cũng khác nhau ID
trùng nhau thì mới là lạ chứ còn ID khác
nhau thì là chuyện bình thường đó.
Thông thường dư nó bị trùng thường hay
là do quá trình người ta thứ nhất là
người ta nhập liệu sai. Hai là gì? Hai
khi khi mà người ta nối bảng người ta
nối giữa hai bảng với nhau thì vô tình
cái sấy lại nằm trong cả hai bảng. Thế
khi nối vào nó sẽ bị trùng lặp như này
thì nó bình thường nó chỉ là một căn
thôi. Chẳng qua tôi nối từ hai nguồn dữ
liệu vào nó thành hai căn thì tôi sẽ
loại bỏ bớt đi nh
>> anh ơi. Vậy thì
>> à cái cái này ờ cái này mình mình ghi
nhầm nhá. Đúng rồi. Cái này nó cái n flo
khác nhau. Mình mình ghi nhầm các bạn
nhá. Nếu mà cái new flow nó giống nhau
cơ. Đây là hai căn khác nhau. Không mình
nhập mình vào mình nhập nhầm đấy nhá.
Hai căn này nếu mà đúng không? Cái nu
flo này ví dụ là nó cùng là 5 hoặc cùng
cung là 4 thì hai cái này nó trùng nhau
nhá. Mình đi nhầm mình sửa lại nhá.
>> À không không sao ạ. Em muốn hỏi là
>> sửa lại không? trường hợp là mình biết
chắc là nó bị lặp số liệu do là mình
ghép bảng hay như nào đó thì mình mới bỏ
đi đúng không ạ? Còn không thì nó vẫn là
một một cái ngôi nhà khác chứ. Đúng. Nếu
nếu nếu mà chúng ta biết chắc chắn là
đây là hai ngôi nhà khác nhau chúng ta
giữ lại. Nếu chúng ta có một cái cơ chế
chúng ta biết chẽ rắn là đây là hai căn
khác nhau thì chúng ta giữ lại. Đấ bởi
vì em theo em thì em hiểu là
như kiểu hai người sinh đôi thì hoàn
toàn giấu hệt nhau mà. Nhưng mà người ta
vẫn hai người riêng biệt.
Đúng rồi. Nếu chúng ta biết chắc chắn
đấy là hai dữ liệu vô tình nó trùng nhau
về mọi th thông thông tin chúng ta giữ
lại. Còn nếu không thì chúng ta xóa đi.
>> Vâng.
>> Ừ.
Đúng rồi. Nếu chúng ta có càng nhiều
chúng ta có càng nhiều thông tin hơn thì
nó cái khả năng nó trụ lập nó sẽ ít hơn
đúng không? Nếu chúng ta có thêm cả
quận, cả phường mọi rất nhiều thông tin
nữa mà nó vẫn trùng thì khả năng cao là
chúng ta bị dư thừa. Đ
rồi quay có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Nào có thắc mắc gì nữa không?
Mỗi phầm dữ liệu có rất nhiều data thì
mình có nhìn vào đánh giá hết các cái
trường hợp. Thường mình sẽ không phải
nhìn đâu, mình sẽ dùng thống mình sẽ
dùng cái thống kê những cái con số để
mình biết xem là có cái outer hay không
chứ còn rượu mà nhiều mình nhìn bằng mắt
thường mình sẽ không nhìn được.
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp các bạn nhá. Tiếp nhá.
À đến đâu rồi ấy nhỉ? Đến out layer nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này, bây giờ chúng ta sẽ
nói về một cái một cái thống kê nữa mà
các bạn đã được học trong môn sá suất
thống kê rồi. Đó là variance. Variance
tiếng Việt mình gọi là phương sai đúng
không? Tiếng Việt mình gọi là phương
sai. Thì các bạn nhìn nhá. Các bạn nhìn
này.
Bây giờ chúng ta chúng ta giả sử chúng
ta có hai cái feature đi nhá. Chúng ta
có hai cái feature. Một cái feature mà
hoặc là cái ví dụ này đi nhá. Giả sử đi,
giả sử bây giờ các bạn có một cái nhóm
bạn nhá. Các bạn có có một cái nhóm bạn,
các bạn có nhóm bạn này có ba đứa. Được
chưa? Ba đứa này thì chiều cao chúng nó
rất là khác biệt nhau. Một đứa cao 1,
đứa cao 1,6, một đứa cao 18. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ các bạn thì chơi với chúng
nó. Các bạn chưa bao giờ các bạn lấy
thước đi đo chúng nó cả. Nhưng mà các
bạn biết là chiều cao chúng nó như thế
nào đúng không? Thế bây giờ giả sử bây
giờ có một cái trò chơi là gì? Là bây
giọ người người ta sẽ hỏi các bạn là bây
giờ người ta sẽ cho các bạn là cái số đo
chiều cao của một người và các bạn phải
đoán xem cái số đo này nó là chiều cao
của cái đứa nào trong ba đứa này. Đúng
không? Thì các bạn mặc dù các bạn chưa
từng lấy thước các bạn đo chúng nó bao
giờ nhưng mà các bạn rất thể dễ dàng các
bạn phân biệt được là à thằng A là thằng
cao nhất 8, thằng B C4, thằng C,6 đúng
không? Tức là đây là cái trường hợp mà
gì? Khi mà chiều cao của những cái đứa
bạn này nó khác biệt nhau rất là nhiều
đúng không? Cái giải giá trị của nó dao
động rất là lớn thì lúc này các bạn cái
việc các bạn phân biệt giữa ba đứa này
nó rất là dễ. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ có
một cái nhóm bạn thứ hai.
Nhóm thứ hai là cái nhóm mà có ba đứa mà
chiều cao của chúng nó cứ xêm xêm nhau.
Được chưa? Chiều nó xêm xêm nhau tức là
1 thằng 170, một thằng 1771, một thằng
172 m. Thế thì bây giờ ấy nếu b các bạn
phải phân biệt chiều cao của ban này sẽ
rất là khó cho các bạn. Tại vì sao? Tại
vì cái mức độ dao động chiều cao của ban
này nó rất là thấp đúng không? Tức là
với con người chúng ta chúng ta sẽ có
cái xu hướng chúng ta sẽ dễ dàng phân
biệt những cái thứ mà có cái giải giá
trị nó lớn đúng không? Ví dụ cái trường
hợp đầu tiên giá trị là từ 1,4 đến 1,6 à
đến 1,8 m đúng không? Giải giá trị nó
lớn thì phân biệt nó sẽ dễ. Còn cái
trường hợp mà cái giải giá trị của nó nó
bé đúng không? Nó chỉ từ 17 đến 172 thôi
thì cái việc chúng ta phân biệt giữa
người này với kia nó sẽ khó hơn. Thế thì
với con người như thế nào? Thì với máy
móc với các cái mô hình trong merching
nó cũng y chang như vậy.
Đối với các cái feature dạng số ấy thì
mô hình nó sẽ có cái xu hướng nó sẽ
thích, nó sẽ ưu tiên hơn những cái
feature mà có cái giải giá trị nó lớn.
Ví dụ có những cái feature mà cái giải
giá trị từ 0 đến 1000 chẳng hạn thì nó
sẽ thích hơn là các cái feature có cái
giải giá trị từ 0 cho đến 10. Được chưa?
Ông nào cái giải giá trị nó càng lớn,
cái sự phân biệt giữa min với max nó
càng lớn thì mô hình lại càng thích tập
trung vào đấy. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nhìn
vào nó thì dễ phân biệt, dễ phân biệt
ông này với ông kia. Chứ còn cái ông mà
giải thị nó nó bé ấy thì mô hình nó sẽ
ít tập trung vào cái feature này. Thế
nhưng mà nếu mà như vậy ấy thì nó sẽ có
một cái tình huống đó là gì? Đó là khi
chúng ta bắt đầu quá trình huấn luyện sẽ
có khả năng là mô hình nó sẽ bị thiên vị
cho một vài những cái feature chỉ vì cái
giải giá trị của nó lớn chứ không phải
vì nó quan trọng. Mình đã cho bạn một
cái ví dụ này. Giả sử bây giờ trong cái
bộ rượu bạn nó có hai cái feature về
quãng đường.
Một cái feature là có đơn vị là km và
một feature đơn vị là m đi. Cái feature
về m ấy thì có cái giải giải giá trị là
từ 0 đến 10.000. Trong khi cái feature
về km ấy thì có giá trị là từ 0 cho đến
10. Đúng không? Rõ ràng chúng ta là con
người chúng ta đều hiểu là gì? Từ 0 đến
10 km thì cũng tương đương với việc là
từ 0 đến 10.000 m đúng không? Nó chả
khác gì nhau cả. Nó y trang nhau. Thế
nhưng cái mô hình nó sẽ không hiểu điều
đấy. Mô hình nó không biết là km m nó
khác nhau cái gì. Nó chỉ biết là mỗn ông
từ 0 đến 10, một ông từ 0 đến 1000 à
10.000 thì mô hình nó sẽ tự nhiên nó sẽ
tập trung nhiều hơn vào cái ông có cái
giải giá trị từ 0 đến 10.000. Trong khi
thực tế thì ông này chưa chắc là nó đã
quan trọng hơn đúng không? Thế thì bây
giờ ấy khi chúng ta huấn luyện một cái
mô hình machining, giả sử chúng ta có
toàn các cái feure dạng số đi đúng
không? Thì chúng ta muốn là gì? Chúng ta
muốn là khi chúng ta bắt đầu quá trình
huấn luyện ấy thì mô hình nó phải đối xử
một cách bình đẳng với các cái feature
còn sau đó thì trong quá trình chúng ta
huấn luyện thì cái feature nào nó quan
trọng hơn thì lôi mô hình nó sẽ tập
trung vào đấy nhiều hơn đúng không? Thì
đấy là cái đoạn mà ở phía sau đúng
không? Nhưng chúng ta muốn là gì? Chúng
ta muốn là khi bắt đầu thì mô hình nó
phải công bằng với tất cả mọi feature
đúng không? Mô hình sẽ phải công bằng
với tất cả mọi feature đấy. Đúng không?
Nó cũng giống như kiểu là lúc các bạn
bắt đầu học thì các bạn phải học tất cả
các môn đều nhau. Trong quá trình học
các bạn sẽ biết là à môn toán với môn
văn nó quan trọng hơn tại vì cái hệ số
nó cao hơn thì tôi sẽ tập trung vào hai
cái môn này hơn. Còn những cái môn kia
tôi sẽ ít tập trung hơn đúng không?
Nhưng mà lúc bắt đầu xuất phát thì các
bạn phải đối xử với mọi môn nó y hệt
nhau đúng không? Thế có nghĩa là gì? Có
nghĩa là với các cái fe trở dạng số á
đúng không? Mặc dù chúng là cái dạng mà
mô hình nó đã tự nhiên nó hiểu rồi nhưng
nếu chúng ta muốn cái việc là quá trình
huấn luyện nó tránh cái sự thiên vị của
các cái mô hình cho các cái feature có
cái giải giá có cái giải giá trị lớn
đúng không? Chúng ta muốn tránh sự thiên
vị như vậy chúng ta muốn là các cái
feature lúc ban đầu được xuất phát công
bằng thì chúng ta sẽ phải có một cái
bước chúng ta tiền xử lý để làm sao
chúng ta đưa các cái feature dạng số của
chúng ta đang từ những cái giải giá trị
khác nhau về những cái giá về những cái
giải giá trị bằng nhau hoặc là tương
đương nhau nhá. bằng nhau là tương nhau.
Thấy không?
Đấy là cái lý do vì sao mà feature dạng
số nó đã là cái dạng mà mô hình nó hiểu
rồi nhưng chúng ta vẫn phải tiền xử lý.
Chúng ta vẫn phải tiền xử lý để chúng ta
đảm bảo là các feature này được đối xử
một cách công bằng. Không có bi không có
thiên vị. Được chưa? Thế thế với xử lý
dệu dạng số ấy thì nó sẽ có hai kiểu cơ
bản nhá. Nó sẽ có hai kiểu cơ bản. Các
bạn nhìn này. Ví dụ mình đang có một cái
feature là về điểm đi được chưa? Đây là
cái feature về điểm chẳng hạn đúng
không? Thì cái cách xử lý đầu tiên ấy là
chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ làm một cái việc
người chúng ta gọi là normalization.
Normalization có nghĩa là gì? Tức là bây
giờ từ cái cột grade này các bạn sẽ tính
xem là cái giá trị nhỏ nhất là bằng bao
nhiêu, giá trị lớn nhất là bằng bao
nhiêu, đúng không? Sau đó thì với mỗi
một cái giá trị này 6
3 12 này, đúng không? Với mỗi một cái
giá trị này các bạn sẽ làm cái gì? Các
bạn sẽ lấy cái giá giá trị khốc ban đầu
các bạn trừ cho min sau các bạn chia cho
max trừ min.
Sau khi các bạn chuẩn hóa như này xong
ấy thì các bạn sẽ được cái output là
những cái giá trị nằm trong khoảng từ
từ mấy đến mấy hả các bạn? Output là giá
trị là khoảng từ mấy đến mấy các bạn?
Output sẽ là giá trị nằm trong khoảng từ
mấy đến mấy các bạn?
Từ min tới max.
Từ min tới max á.
Nào đúng rồi. Từ 0 đến 1 đúng không? Từ
0 đến 1 đúng không? Bất kể cái input ban
đầu các cái giá trị của bạn nó là từ âm
vô cùng đến dương vô cùng hay là bao
nhiêu đấy nó to nó bé đến mấy nhưng mà
sau khi các bạn xử lý này ấy thì cái giá
trị output của các bạn sẽ luôn nằm trong
khoảng từ 0 cho đến 1 được chưa? Thì bất
kể lúc ban đầu các bạn có một cái
feature là từ 0 đến 10 một cái ông là từ
0 đến 10.000 đi. Các bạn đi qua đây nó
tất cả về 0 đến 1 hết tất cả về 0 đến 1
hết đúng không? Thì đây là một cách
chúng ta có thể dùng chúng ta tiền xử lý
các cái dữ liệu dạng số đ không người ta
gọi đây là normalization được chưa?
Normalization.
Cái cách thứ hai là gì? Cái cách thứ hai
là bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thay vì chúng ta
tìm min với tìm max chúng ta sẽ tìm ra
kỳ vọng với cả độ lệch chuẩn của cái cột
đấy. Đúng không? Thì chúng ta ra kỳ vọng
bằng bao nhiêu đấy. Độ đại lệ chuẩn bằng
bao nhiêu đấy? Đúng. Sau chúng ta sẽ lấy
giá trị gốc ban đầu trừ cho kỳ vọng rồi
chia cho độ lệ chuẩn nhá. Giá trị gốc
ban đầu các cái giá trị này 6 8 2 3 này
đúng không? Từng giá trị một chúng ta sẽ
trừ cho kỳ vọng và chia cho đổi chuẩn.
để ra cái output này. Các bạn cho mình
hỏi này, nếu chúng ta biến đổi như thế
này thì theo các bạn cái giá trị output
phần lớn các cái giá trị output này nó
sẽ nằm trong khoảng từ bao nhiêu đến bao
nhiêu?
Phần lớn các cái giá trị output này sẽ
nằm trong khoảng từ bao nhiêu đến bao
nhiêu?
Nào kiểm tra kiến thức xác thống kê.
Phần lớn cái output này nằm trong khoảng
từ bao nhiêu đến bao nhiêu các bạn?
Các
bài khác thì sao?
Lớp này ít bạn được học môn số thống kê
đến một đấy cả.
Theo mình biết là các cái trường đại học
dù các bạn học kỹ thuật hay là kinh tế
các bạn đều phải học qua sáu rất thống
kê mà kỹ thuật cũng phải học, kinh tế
cũng phải học đúng không? Từ bao nhiêu
đến bao nhiêu? Đúng rồi, từ -3 đến 3. Vì
sao? Đúng rồi, hầu hết chúng không phải
toàn bộ nhưng mà hầu hết chúng sẽ nằm
trong khoảng từ -3 đến 3. Lý do là vì
vì sao nhỉ?
Đúng -3 đến 3 thì đúng rồi.
99 ph bao nhiêu phần trăm bé một khoản
từ -3 đến 3 đúng. Nhưng lý do là vì sao?
Vì sao lại là -3 mà không phải -4 hay là
-2?
Lý do là vì
à hay quá các bạn đọc được cái tên rồi.
Đúng rồi. Phân chuẩn đúng không?
Phân đội chuẩn thì anh đọc là gì? Phân
chuẩn thì anh đọc là gì?
Anh đọc là gì? Có hai cái tên chân chuẩn
t anh có hai cái tên
là đọc được tên của phân v chuẩn nào
normal distribution hoặc là
distribution đúng rồi
này. Phân độ chuẩn này đúng không? Đúng
không? Phần lớn dữ liệu sẽ nằm trong
khoảng ba lần đồ lệ chuẩn không 99,7 thế
này được chưa?
Tất nhiên ấy thật ra ấy công bằng mà nói
ra ấy cái phép biến đổi này các bạn nó
sẽ không biến diệu bạn đang từ phân phối
bất kỳ thành phân phối chuẩn đâu. Nhưng
mà nó sẽ giúp các bạn phân phối bạn nó
sẽ gần với chuẩn hơn đúng không? Gần với
chuẩn hơn mà nếu nó là chuẩn ấy thì nó
sẽ nằm trong khoảng từ -3 cho đến 3.
Nhìn chung là gì? Phép biến đối này tóm
lại là ruệ các bạn phần lớn nó sẽ nằm
trong khoảng từ -3 cho đến 3. Được chưa?
Cái đầu tiên thì có là normalization.
Cái thứ hai gọi là standardization.
Đối với normalization các bạn có biết là
nhược điểm của cái phương pháp này là là
gì không? Ưu điểm là cái output nó sẽ
luôn luôn nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 1.
Rất là dễ giải thích đúng không? Không
có ngoại lệ. Các cái giá trị output chỉ
nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 1 thôi. Nhưng
nó cũng có nhược điểm. Nhược điểm là gì?
Nhược điểm là gì?
À đúng rồi, nó chịu ảnh hưởng outer cụ
thể hơn được không? Cụ thể hơn đi. Đúng
rồi, nó chịu ảnh hưởng của outer đúng cụ
thể hơn một chút.
Vì sao chịu ảnh hưởng của outlayer?
Tại vì outlayer nếu mà nó có xuất hiện
ấy thì nó thường làm sao?
Tại vì nếu mà đúng rồi mà nó có tồn tại
ấ thường nó sẽ là max hoặc là min hoặc
thậm chí nó cả max cả min mà khi nó sẽ
bị kéo nó sẽ kéo cả cái phân phối lệch
sang một phía đúng không? Nó sẽ kéo cả
cái phân phối output ra lệch ra một phía
đúng không? O outer mà có thì thường
thường thông thường nó hay là rơi vào
min hoặc max và có thể trường hợp tai
hại nó có thể rơi vào cả hai luôn đúng
không? Chúng ta muốn như này, chúng ta
muốn là sau khi mà chúng ta tiền xử lý ấ
đúng không? Các cái giá trị nó khoảng từ
0 đến 1 kiểu kiểu như này này. Tức là ví
dụ đây là 0 nhá, đây là 1 nhá. Chúng ta
muốn các cái giá trị cứ đều đều đều đấy.
Nó cứ đều đều phân vố đều đều này. Đấy
kiểu kiểu như này. Đấy chúng ta muốn nó
như này. Thế nhưng mà nếu mà al nó nằm
vào max ho min ý thì nó sẽ kiểu kiểu như
này. Tức là một là nó sẽ rơi hết vào
đây. Đấy như này đấy đúng không? Hai là
nó rơi hết vào như này. Đấy kiểu kiểu
như này. Đấy nó sẽ bị lệch hẳn sang mọng
bên. Chúng ta không muốn lệch như này.
Chúng ta muốn nó có phải đều đều đều đều
đều này cơ. Đấy đúng không? Thì đây
chính cái nhược điểm của của
cách tiếp cận đầu tiên, cái cách mà
người ta gọi là normalization đấy này
đúng không? Đây gọi là normalization,
đây gọi là standardization đúng không?
Tiếng Việt mình dịch ra thì hình như là
đều là chuẩn hóa. Mình cũng chả biết
dịch ra tiếng Việt khác nhau như thế nào
nhưng mà hai từ này thì đấy nếu mà dịch
tiếng Việt thì thì đều gọi là chuẩn hóa
nh mỗi chuẩn hóa một kiểu. Một cái là
dựa vào min với max, một cái là dựa vào
kỳ vọng với đồ lệnh chuẩn. Được chưa?
Cái cách này nó có bị ảnh hưởng bởi alle
không các bạn? Standarization này nó có
bị ảnh hưởng bởi outlayer không?
Standarizion có bị ảnh hưởng bởi
outlayer không?
Có bị gì không?
Cái này có bị ảnh hưởng về outer không?
Đúng rồi đấy. Người ta thường người ta
hay dùng hay dùng cái cái standation này
ta phát hiện outayer đấy. Thường ta hay
dùng tức là ông nào mà rơi quá quá quá
rơi nằm ngoài ba lần đội chuẩn chúng ta
sẽ bỏ đi. Đấy
nào các bạn station có bị ảnh hưởng với
không?
Nó có bị ảnh hưởng như nó rất ít đúng
không? Nó có bị ảnh hưởng như nó ít hơn
rất nhiều so với min max. Tại vì sao? A
layer ấy nếu nó có nó cũng chỉ là một
trong số những cái giá trị tham gia tính
và min với cả standard deviation thôi
đúng không? Nó có ảnh hưởng nhưng cái
ảnh hưởng nó ít hơn rất là nhiều so với
min max so so với là các bạn dùng
normalization này. Được chưa? Cái đây
nhá. Đây là hai cách xử lý cơ bản dành
cho liệu dạng số đúng không? Để các bạn
có thể đưa các cái feature về các cái
giải giá trị nó giống nhau hoặc là tương
đương nhau. Được chưa? Đấy tiếp nhá.
Thì tiếp theo thì cái loại tiếp theo là
gì? Cái loại ordinal feature. Ordinal
feature chúng ta học từ hôm trước rồi.
Ordinal feature đâu rồi?
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đây đúng không? Chúng ta có ordinal đúng
không? Ordinal feature là các cái thuộc
tính mà có cái một quan hệ thứ bậc gì
đây đúng không?
Đây đúng không? Thì các bạn rất là dễ
thôi. Mán này dọn số thôi đúng không?
Các bạn có k giá trị khác nhau thì các
bạn phải chỉ ra một cái thứ tự gì đấy
các bạn sẽ mã hóa chúng là từ 0 cho đến
k - 1 đúng không? Các bạn có năm giá trị
khác nhau đúng không? Xs ml xl đúng
không? Thì các bạn sẽ m hóa từ 0 cho đến
4. Đó. Từ 0 cho đến 4. Thôi
tiếp này các bạn này. Với dữ liệu dạng
nominal
à chết nghỉ ra 5 phút các bạn nhá. Nghỉ
ra 5 phút nhá. Quá giờ quá giờ ra 5 phút
nhá. Được chưa? 5 phút mình nói tiếp
nhá. Bạn nào các bạn có câu hỏi gì bạn
cứ hỏi nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi
nhá.
Rồi thì các bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
>> Anh ơi tại sao mình phải mình phải chuẩn
hóa số liệu số vậy thầy? Mình muốn nói
>> bởi vì cái đoạn trước anh nói như thế
nhưng mà em tưởng đấy là cái đặc điểm
của các cái bản ghi mình biết như thế
thì tại sao mình lại chuyển nó về?
Tại vì như này, nếu mình không chuyển về
thì mô hình nó sẽ có cái xu hướng nó tập
trung nhiều hơn vào những cái feature nó
có cái giải giá trị lớn và nó sẽ ít tập
trung hơn vào những cái feature có giải
giá trị nhỏ. Thế nhưng mà cái vấn đề ở
đây là không phải cái feature nào có
giải giá trị lớn là nó sẽ tự nhiên nó
quan trọng hơn. Mà nhiều khi ý có cái
feature cái giải giá trị nó lớn chẳng
qua là do cái do cái thang chia của nó
nó là như thế. Như mình vừa mới nói rồi
đúng không? từ 0 đến 10 km và từ 0 đến
10.000 m là hoàn toàn tương đương nhau
đúng không? Nhưng mà nếu chúng ta cứ để
nguyên như vậy á, chúng ta để nguyên như
vậy á thì cái mô hình của chúng ta ấy nó
sẽ tập trung hơn và cái feature có cái
giải giá trị từ 0 đến 10.000 tại vì cái
giải nó lớn hơn đúng không? Chúng ta
muốn tránh cái việc như vậy. Chúng ta
muốn là cái quá trình bắt đầu ấy, lúc
bắt đầu mô hình nó phải đối xử bình đẳng
với mọi feature rồi sau này khi feature
nào nó quan trọng hơn thì lúc đấy mô
hình nó sẽ tập trung hơn vào. Thì lúc
đấy mình phải chuẩn hóa để sao mình đưa
cái feature này về cùng một giải. Còn
nếu các bạn cứ để nguyên cái giải như
ban đầu ấy thì những cái feature mà có
cái giải giá trị cái mức độ chênh lệch
nó từ bé đến từ min đến max nó bé mô
hình sẽ rất ít khi nhìn vào cái feature
đấy. Được chưa?
Không cái vừa nãy mình chỉ nói liên quan
đến nó chỉ dựa họ số thôi. Còn còn còn
cái sau khi các bạn để xong các bạn để
nguyên các bạn không cần phải chuẩn hóa
không phải chuẩn hóa tiếp nhá. Ordin
chuyẩn xong này từ 0 này có để nguyên
vừa là cái quy tắc vừa nó chỉ so dánh
dựa vào các cái numerical feature với
nhau thôi nhá.
>> Em hỏi một chút.
>> Ừ ví dụ như là một cái đặc điểm nào đó
ví dụ như là diện tích căn nhà đi
>> ừ
>> thì nó từ khoảng từ 100 m² đến 1000 m²
chẳng hạn.
>> [hắng giọng]
>> Thì theo mình theo ban đầu mình mình
đánh giá là cái giải giá trị của nó rất
là rộng và có thể máy nó sẽ nhìn vào đó
đúng không ạ?
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thì nhưng mà trong trường hợp hai cái
lần hai cái phương pháp mà mình chuẩn
hóa số liệu dữ liệu ấy anh
>> thì
>> có khi nào mà nó sẽ bị theo kiểu là nó
sẽ
nó bị giống nhau không? bị giống nhau.
Tức là tức là
>> tức là ví dụ như là khoảng từ từ 100 m²
đến 200 m² là nó sẽ chuẩn hóa thành một
số thôi ấy. Hoặc là nó bởi vì em thấy là
như cái
>> cái ví dụ anh đưa ra ấy thì nó chỉ có
một số sau số phẩy thôi thì
liệu có nhiều cái khoảng khoảng hiển
nhiên là nó khác nhau nhá.
dụ 100 m² và 200 m² thì hoàn thành nhiên
là nó rất là khác biệt rồi.
>> Đúng.
>> Nhưng mà khi mà chuẩn hóa xong ấy thì nó
lại bằng 0,3 giống nhau. Vì hiển nhiên
là không còn dấu phẩy số nào có dấu phẩy
nữa là thì liệu như thế nó có làm mình
có thể làm cho máy nó học sai sai dữ
liệu không ạ?
>> Vì sao ở đây lại chỉ có 0,63 0,84? Tại
vì cái chỗ nó chỉ đứng đấy thôi. Bây giờ
anh cũng không thể nào anh viết 10 số
đằng sau được đúng không? Trong thực tế
người ta đâu có bị giới hạn đâu. Chẳng
qua đây là cái slide mình không viết
được nhiều đúng không? Còn quy tắc này
là gì? Hai input độ vào khác nhau không
bao giờ tạo ra được hai output giống
nhau đúng không? 100 và 200 là hai input
khác nhau không thể nào có phép biến đổi
nào lại ra hai cái output giống nhau.
Chẳng qua đây là chỗ nó chỉ có từ có
từng này thôi thì anh chỉ viết được từng
này thôi đúng không? Đưa vào mô hình nó
đâu bị giới hạn đâu đúng không?
Đúng không? Hai input khác nhau không
bao giờ ra được cùng một output. Chắ là
như thế.
Cái mà em vừa nói là làm tròn đúng
không? Nhưng mà trong thực tế có ai
người ta làm tròn bao giờ đâu? Làm tròn
đâu có tác dụng gì đâu đúng không? Làm
tròn chỉ dùng khi chúng ta muốn show dữ
liệu ra thôi. Shu ra bảng biểu báo cáo
thôi. Người ta làm tròn chứ đưa vào mô
hình có ai người ta làm tròn bao giờ
đâu.
>> Bởi vì thực ra làm tròn làm tròn người
ta vẫn có quy tắc làm tròn. Ví dụ như là
ngay cả pi value người ta chỉ lấy ba số
thôi mà anh
>> đúng nhưng đấy là làm tròn để show ra
ngoài màn hình để viết báo cáo. Còn đưa
vào mô hình đâu để có ai người ta làm
tròn bao giờ đâu. Đưa vào mô hình thì
làm tròn đâu có tác tác dụng đâu. Làm
tròn nó chỉ để làm gì? Để nhìn cho nó
dễ. Nhưng chúng ta đưa vào mô hình mà
chúng ta đâu có dùng để chúng ta nhìn
đâu. Đây là chẳng qua là show lên slide
thì chỉ viết hai số thôi chứ bây giờ
viết 10 số thì có ai nhìn đâu. Đúng
không? Nhưng đưa vào mô hình người ta
quay người ta làm tròn ở đâu?
Làm tròn là để display là để trình bày
ra. Còn đưa vào mô hình trái người ta
làm tròn bao giờ.
>> Vậy tức là máy chia ra bao nhiêu thì
mình nó sẽ học đúng cái số đấy chứ chư.
>> Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Chia bao nhiêu nó
học đúng số đấy. Nó sẽ không làm tròn.
Nó sẽ không không có cái gì làm tròn cả.
làm tròn gì thì chúng ta show ra viết
báo cáo, viết đảng biểu, viết report cho
nó dễ thôi.
Anh ơi giả sử như
cái khoảng giá trị nó lớn thì mình mới
nghĩ đến việc chuẩn hóa số liệu. Nhưng
mà nếu mà cái khoảng cái cái giá trị nó
lớn nhưng mà cái cái khoảng giá trị của
nó lại hẹp thì kệ đó nhỉ. Thế này chúng
ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ chuẩn hóa khi mà khi
mà khi mà cái range cái giải tức là gì?
Tức là tức là cái giải giá trị của các
cái feature nó khác biệt nhau. Nó khác
biệt nhau. Tức là một ông ví dụ là một
ông từ một ông từ 0 đến 10.000, một ông
từ 0 đến a 10 ví dụ như vậy. Thế còn nếu
mà các cái giá trị nó nó lớn nhưng mà nó
lại lớn đều với nhau. Ví dụ là ví dụ một
cái bức ảnh đi. Các cái pixel của bức
ảnh nó đều đều đều từ 0 đến 25 năm cả.
Ông nào cũng từ 0 đến 25 thì 2 năm tuy
nó lớn nhưng mà chúng sẽ không phải
chuẩn hóa tại vì nó giống nhau hết rồi.
Giống nhau hết rồi. Đấy
chúng ta chuẩn hóa không phải là do nó
lớn mà do là có ông lớn ông bé thì mới
phải chuẩn hóa chứ còn nếu mà lớn cùng
lớn bé cùng bé thì lại không cần
chúng cái việc cho chuẩn hóa này để
chúng ta tránh cái việc là môi nh ban
đầu nó bị focus nhiều hơn nó bị bias về
một cái feature và nó ít ít quan tâm đến
những cái feature khác. Thế còn nếu mà
tất cả cùng một giải rồi thì không phải
không phải chẩn hóa nữa.
Nhưng em hỏi một chút nhá.
>> Là cái
>> thật em tò mò em hỏi thôi
>> là
>> cái khoảng giá cái khoảng giá trị mà
mình nghĩ là nó lớn hay là nó nhỏ hay là
nó hẹp thì đấy do mình nghĩ thôi chứ
>> không phải không không phải mình không
có nghĩ mình thống kê. Mình thống kê
mình mình không nghĩ mình thống kê. Mình
phải thống kê.
>> Bởi vì bởi vì ngay cả ví dụ anh nói là 1
đến 25 pixel đúng không? Thì nếu mà mình
coi là dụ mỗi khoảng năm đơn vị pixel
thì là lớn thì là thì mình nghĩ việc
chuyển hóa đúng không? Còn nếu mà mình
nghĩ là 50 ví dụ là 10 đơn vị pixel mà
vẫn nhỏ thì mình cứ kệ được thôi đúng
không? Không không cái này nó không phải
mình nghĩ anh nói này ờ mình không có
nghĩ nếu mà chỉ có mình không có nghĩ
mình phải so sánh cái giải giá trị giữa
các cái giữa các cái feure nhau mình
không có nghĩ mình dựa vào thống kê mình
dựa vào thống kê ờ
ví dụ ví dụ hai feature đấy ví dụ như
anh vừa nói là ví dụ mà ờ một cái
feature là về hai feature đều về độ dài
đi. Một cái là từ 0 đến 10 cây, một cái
là từ 0 đến 10.000 m đúng không? Thì mô
hình nó đâu có hiểu km với m đâu. Nó chỉ
biết là một ông từ 0 đến 10, một ông từ
0 đến 10.000 1000 thì tự nhiên mình sẽ
auto lại tập trung hơn cái âm từ 0 đến
10.000 đúng không? Trong khi về mặt ý
nghĩa chúng nó chẳng khác gì nhau cả
đúng không? Ý nghĩa chúng nó tương đương
nhau mà chẳng qua là cái giải giá trị
chúng nó khác nhau thôi đúng không? Thì
đấy là trường hợp chúng ta phải chuẩn
hóa.
Nhớ chưa? Còn
>> hỏi một chút nhá. Ừ. Em hỏi đi.
>> Bởi vì à
ví dụ như là cái khoảng giá trị của
dụ tiền tệ đi.
>> Ừ.
>> Ví dụ như anh nói là dụ à đơn vị là
triệu thì nó sẽ nhỏ đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Nhưng mà đơn vị của anh là tỷ cơ thì từ
triệu đến tỷ nó sẽ rất nhiều số không và
nhìn nó sẽ lớn đúng không anh?
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Như vậy mình chỉ việc đổi đơn vị thành
cái đơn vị tiền tệ lớn hơn thì cái số
của nó dụ từ 100 nó sẽ về 1 thôi đúng
không anh? Tức là tóm lại làm sao mình
đưa các cái feure của mình về những giải
giá trị nó bằng nhau hoặc nó tương đương
nhau là được đúng không? Còn cách nào
không quan trọng, cách có thể hai cái
này hoặc các bạn ấy có thể bỏ số không
bớt đi cũng được, không có vấn đề gì cả.
Không biết làm sao các bạn đưa nó về một
cái giải tương đương nhau. Tại vì nếu
không ấy nếu chúng ta cứ để nguyên như
vậy ấ thì sẽ có những cái feature mà cái
giải nó lớn hơn tự nhiên mô hình nó sẽ
auto nó sẽ focus vào đấy. Cũng giống như
kiểu con người phân biệt thôi. Cái ông
nào mà cái giá trị nó lệch nhiều tức là
cái mức độ phân tán nó lớn cái variant
nó lớn ấy thì mọi người tập trung hơn
vào chỗ đấy.
Ờ nếu mà chúng ta làm như vậy mà kỹ
thuật thì cũng được nhưng mà đấy nó sẽ
tạo tức là một ông normal một ông center
line thì sẽ tạo ra hai ông có hai cái
giải giá trị khác nhau. Thì thường người
ta sẽ không làm như vậy. Một là normal
thì normal cả. hay là standardiz chứ còn
ít khi người ta pha cả hai cái vào với
nhau.
Nếu mặc định lúc nào cũng có chuẩn hóa
thì có ok không?
Nếu mà các cái feature của chúng ta, các
cái feature dạng số ấy mà cái mức độ
phân tán nó giống nhau, nó tương đương
nhau, cái giá trị nó lớn giống nhau thì
các bạn không chuẩn hóa. Các bạn chuẩn
hóa thì cũng
chuẩn hóa thì cũng được thôi nhưng mà nó
cũng chả giúp gì cả đúng không? Nó chỉ
hữu ích khi mà cái giải trị nó khác nhau
thôi. Còn khi nó cùng giải giá trị rồi
thì các bạn chuẩn hóa xong thì nó tốn
hết một bước thôi chứ nó cũng chả giúp
gì cả. Và có những thuật toán các bạn
chú ý nhá. Có những thuật toán là ngoại
lệ. Tức là gì? Có những thuật toán nó
miễn nhiễm với cái việc là giải giá trị
lớn hay bé. Thuật toán nào? Thì trong
những buổi sau chúng ta học về cái
thuing thì có một cái họ cái thuật toán
nó hoàn toàn nó miễn nhiễm với cái việc
là giải giá trị các cái dạng số là lớn
hay bé. Bé lớn nó không quan trọng nhá.
Nhưng mà nó chỉ ở ngoại lệ thôi. Nó chỉ
hợp ngoại lệ. Còn hầu hết các cái thuật
toán trong machine nó đều nó đều nó đều
gọi là sensitive với cái việc là giải
giá trị của chúng ta nó lớn hay nó bé.
Được chưa?
Ờ
sau khi loại bỏ sau khi lại bỏ tại vì
out layer mình đâu có nhu cầu mình chuẩn
hóa đâu. Đúng mình sau khi mình loại bỏ
out layer
>> ở Việt Nam data thừ thường hay lấy ở đâu
ạ thầy?
>> À có nhiều nguồn lắm ạ. Cái nguồn phổ
biến nhất là trên các g
>> tức là
>> ừ cái nguồn phổ biến nhất là trên các
trên các nhưng mà vấn đề là trên các g
thì toàn là dữ liệu public
d public thì dùng để học thì ok chứ còn
đi làm thì chả ai người ta lên đ lên
người ta lấy cả đi làm thì công ty của
mình sẽ phải có cái dữ liệu riêng công
ty nó sẽ có cái dữ liệu riêng
lấy vị trí kg đ có nhiều đ set lắm
>> ừ
>> nhưng mà trên này thì ví dụ lấy để học
thì ok chứ còn lấy để đi làm thường
người ta sẽ không lấy để mình đi làm
công ty mình kiểu gì cũng có
Đây là nguồn dữ liệu về về về bảng. Thế
còn dữ liệu mà về ảnh chẳng hạn thì sẽ
có cái nguồn là
đây dữ liệu về ảnh có nguồn như này
trang roboflow này.
Đây nó có rất nhiều đây ru rất nhiều
rảnh này. Ví dụ đây này.
Đấy
rượu này cái rượu của quả bạc bóng này
kiểu như vậy. Nhưng mà
>> game cái này chủ yếu là dùng để làm ví
dụ project làm project cá nhân các thứ
thì người ta lên đây. Thế còn khi đi làm
thì kiểu gì công ty kiểu gì cũng sẽ có
rượu riêng.
Rượu riêng cho nên chúng ta sẽ không
public lên đây.
>> Ừ. [hắng giọng]
Chị thấy
có cái có một cái app gì quay mặt tên à
không biết bên Mỹ thể ở đâu nó trả tiền
cho người ta để người ta gắn mấy cái
chip vào người xong rồi người ta người
ta làm những cái hành động lặp đi lặp
lại trong cuộc sống bình thường ấ xong
người ta gửi vào cái đấy xong
[tiếng cười] giống như kiểu play to earn
ngày xưa ấy xong bây giờ có cái trò là
kiểu data to data to earn
>> đúng rồi là
>> em biết em biết em em từ nghe cái ứng
dụng kiểu cái những cái bên kiểu như vậy
tức là họ thu dữ liệu qua tức là họ muốn
thu hp những cái liên quan đến kiểu Po
estimation tức là cái kiểu như này tức
là người ta muốn đánh nhãn về cử chỉ
kiểu kiểu như này.
>> Ừ. Kiểu như là nó muốn đánh vào người
tiêu dùm những cái behavior kiểu nó
thành cái thói quen ấy.
>> Ờ
>> nó sẽ anh nó sẽ kiểu kiểu như này tức là
chí nó sẽ dụ nó sẽ lấy những cái a à gì
những đây đây là bài toán po estimation
tức là sẽ đánh tức là sẽ lấy cái vị trí
của cái key point trên người của chúng
ta đấy hoặc là chip nó ngắn để nó xem là
các cái cử động thế nào. Thường người ta
hay ứng dụng này để cho cái [hắng giọng]
bên mà phục hồi sau chấn thương ấy,
những người phối sau chấn thương để xem
là cái tư thế của họ có đúng hay không
hoặc là bên nào ví dụ trong an toàn lao
động xem là cái tư thế của của
những người lao động họ có đúng cái tư
thế không, có dễ bị gây ra chấn thương
hay không. Kiểu như vậy hoặc là trong
thể thao trong thể thao chúng ta xem là
ví dụ những người làm những người độ
viên cử tạ chẳng hạn xem cái tư thế của
độ viên cử tạ nó có nó có nó có đúng
theo theo hướng dẫn này không.
>> Rồi các bạn nhá. Thế đây là xử lý dạng
numeric xong rồi đúng không? Numeric
hoặc là numeric feature là dạng số đúng
không? Chúng ta sẽ có hai cách là gì? Là
standard line hoặc là normal đúng không?
Các bạn cứ làm sao các bạn đưa các cái
giá trị về cùng một cái giải tương đương
với nhau là ok được chưa? Đấy tiếp theo
là oral encoder đâ rất là dễ đúng chư ch
chúng ta số hóa nó thôi. Được chưa? Thế
còn cái loại tiếp theo là gì? Là loại
nữa là nominal feature. Với nominal
feature ví dụ các bạn có bốn cái giá trị
khác nhau là black, blue white với cả
green đi đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ dùng
cái kỹ thuật gọi là onhot and coding.
Bạn nào các bạn học IT các bạn không còn
xa lạ gì với kỹ thuật này nữa đúng
không? On hot and coding chúng ta sẽ có
một cái vecơ mà toàn số 0 nó chỉ có đúng
một phần tử nó khác 0 thôi. Được chưa?
Đây gọi là onhot encoding. Được chưa? On
hot encoding. Các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá.
Với cái cái dữ liệu dạng nominal feature
này, nếu mình cứ dùng cái cách như là
này tức là gì? Tôi sẽ mạ hóa là màu đen
là 0, màu xanh là 1, màu màu xanh lá cây
là một, màu xanh nước biển là hai, màu
trắng là 3 đi. Ví dụ mình mã hóa kiểu số
như vậy thì có được không? Mình mình cứ
dùng cái cách của ordinal encoding này
mình mã hóa cho nominal feature thì có
được không?
Được không?
được nhưng tốn dữ liệu hơn ấy. Được
không các bạn?
Quá nhiều không phải vấn đề. Càng nhiều
thì dùng ordinal càng lợi hơn đúng không
các bạn? Đây các bạn có 10 giá trị khác
nhau. Các bạn phải dùng máy vectơ có 10
phần tử. Trong khi các bạn dùng các các
bạn các bạn dùng cái này các bạn chỉ có
một giá trị thôi đúng không? càng nhiều
thì dùng cái ordinal này càng có lợi
đúng không? Nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ không
dùng như vậy đúng không? Vì sao lại
giống như bạn à bạn bạn Hưng mới vừa nói
đúng không? Nếu các bạn dùng cái cách mã
hóa của các bạn mã hóa cho nominal ấy
thì nó sẽ tự nhiên nó sẽ tạo ra một cái
thứ tự giữa các cái giá trị này trong
khi trong thực tế lại không tồn tại đúng
không? Ví dụ là giữa XS, SL, XL thì đúng
là có thứ tự thật nhưng mà giữa các cái
giá trị này làm gì có thứ tự gì đâu đúng
không? Từ các bạn mã hoa là 023 thì bây
giờ mô hình nó sẽ hiểu là có một cái
order, có một cái thứ tự gì đấy giữa các
cái giá trị này đúng không? môi nó sẽ
học cái thứ tự đấy. Trong khi thứ tự đấy
nó lại không tồn tại đúng không? Thì do
đó chúng ta sẽ không làm được. Mặc dù về
mặt kỹ thuật các bạn dùng thì nó vẫn
chạy thôi, nó không có lỗi gì cả. Thế
nhưng mà người ta sẽ không làm như thế
đúng không? Không mai người ta dùng do
dùng encoding để người ta mã hóa cho dữ
liệu dạng nominal cả. Được chưa? Cái
cách cơ hả nhất là dùng onhot. On hot
thì có cái ưu điểm là đơn giản. Các bạn
không dùng thư viện các bạn cũng dùng
onhot được. Thế nhưng mà nhược điểm là
gì? Là nó sẽ rất là tốn tài nguyên.
Nhược điểm nó cực kỳ tốn tài nguyên đúng
không? Đây các bạn chỉ có bốn giá trị
khác nhau thôi. Các bạn mà có khoảng 40
400 4000 thì nó sẽ tốn rất là nhiều tài
nguyên đúng không? Nó tốn rất nhiều tài
nguyên.
Rồi
thế ngoài cách này ra cò còn cách còn
cách nào khác? Thế thì nó còn một cách
khác nữa. Cái cách này nó không phải là
một phương pháp nó là cả một cái hệ
phương pháp. Người ta gọi là word eming.
Wording có nghĩa là gì? Wording có nghĩa
là bây giờ ấy tôi sẽ tôi sẽ mã hóa tôi
sẽ mã hóa các cái tử của tôi thành những
cái vecơ trong không gian nhiều chiều.
Thông thường số chiều của cái vecơ này
sẽ rất là lớn. Nó sẽ phải là 50 chiều,
100, 200 hay là 300. Nhưng ở đây để cho
đơn giản tôi sẽ để tạo trong không gian
ba chiều được chưa? Thì người ta sẽ làm
một việc là người ta sẽ mã hóa các cái
từ thành các cái vecơ trong không gian
nhiều chiều đấy. 100 200 chiều. Thì khi
thấy mã hóa này nó sẽ phải đảm bảo gì?
là các cái từ nào mà thứ nhất nó là
synonym của nhau đúng không? Thứ nhất
các cái từ nó là synonym của nhau. Thứ
hai là các cái từ mà nó hay xuất hiện
trong những cái
ngữ cảnh giống nhau, hay xuất hiện cùng
nhau, hay xuất hiện cùng những cái từ
giống nhau. Đấy thì những cái từ này
thông thường thì chúng nó sẽ gần nhau
trong không gian vecơ. Gần nhau có nghĩa
là gì? Gần nhau có nghĩa là cái góc kẹp
giữa nó sẽ bé.
Góc kẹp giữa này góc kẹp giữa nó sẽ bé
này đúng không? Ví dụ đây cái ví dụ các
bạn nh cái từ fly với từ eagle. Eagle là
cái gì các bạn? Eagle là cái gì đây? Fly
bay eagle là cái gì đây? E là cái gì?
Con gì?
>> Chim à?
>> Đúng rồi. Đúng không? Chim
>> con bàng chim ưng. Đúng rồi. Chim ưng
đúng rồi nhá. Đúng không? Thì bạn nhìn
này. Hai cái hai cái từ này ấy nó có cái
vecơ rất là gần nhau. Gần nhau t góc kẹp
giữa nó bé. Tại vì sao thì chúng nó hay
xuất hiện cùng nhau đúng không? Tức là
gì? Nhưng cái bài báo mà có cái từ Eagle
ấy thường là hay có cái từ fly luôn đúng
không? Hoặc là nó hay xuất hiện trong
những cái khoảnh nó tương tự nhau hoặc
là cloud với cả Eagle nó cũng như thế
đúng không? Thì người ta sẽ có những cái
mô hình để làm sao người ta có thể số
hóa những cái từ này thành những cái
vecơ sao cho các cái vecơ này. Không
những bình thường ấy các bạn dùng onhot
ấy, các bạn dùng onhot thì các bạn chỉ
làm được mỗi một cái việc là gì? Là các
bạn phân biệt được giữa từ này với từ
kia đúng không? Các bạn phân biệt được
giữa black với cả blue white với cả
green. Các bạn phân biệt được từ lion
với cả tiger, tiger với cả dog. Nhưng mà
các bạn sẽ không ma được cái sự gần gũi
giữa chúng đúng không? Đây toàn những
cái vecơ mà hai cái vecơ này nó chúng nó
nó các bạn nhìn này bốc hai vecơ ngẫu
nhiên thì các bạn sẽ thấy là trong không
gian vectơ chúng nó như nào với nhau hai
vecơ này hai vectơ ngẫu nhiên trong này
các bạn bốc chúng ra vẽ lên cho không ra
nhiều chiều chúng nó sẽ như thế nào với
nhau các bạn
lấy hai vecơ ngẫu nhiên các bạn vẽ nó
lên cho không gian nhiều chiều sẽ trong
không gian bốn chiều đ chúng nó sẽ như
thế nào với nhau
vectơ 1 với cả 0100 này vẽ lên trong
không gian bốn chiều chúng nó sẽ như th
nào với nhau
Hai vectơ 1 và 0100 vậy
vuông góc đúng rồi
vuông góc với nhau đúng không? Các vectơ
đôi một vuông góc đúng không? Hệ các cái
vecơ đôi một vuông góc trong toán người
ta gọi là hệ gì các bạn? Hệ mà có nhiều
vecơ ví dụ hệ này có bốn vecơ này 1
này bốn v cái hệ bốn vecơ này mà cứ đôi
một vuông góc với nhau người ta gọi đây
là cái hệ gì các bạn? Hệ trực giao. Đúng
rồi, hệ trực giao không phải vectơ đơn
vị. Đúng là vectơ đơn vị thật. Nhưng mà
cái hệ này gọi là hệ trực giao đúng
không? Hệ trực giao. Hệ tọa độ là hệ là
cái hệ các bạn vẽ bình thường rồi. Oxy
là hệ trục tọa độ, oxyz là hệ trục tọa
độ. Rồi đây là hệ trực giao. Hệ trực
giao mà độ dài của mỗi một vectơ đều
bằng 1 thì gọi là hệ gì?
Hệ trực giao mà độ giải của các mỗi một
cái vecơ đều bằng 1 thì gọi là hệ gì?
gọi là hệ
trường chuẩn. Đúng rồi.
Bạn Hưng ngày xưa cấp ba bạn học bạn học
bạn học có học chuyên gì không?
Cấp ba bạn học chuyên gì không?
Ừ đúng rồi. Chuyên toán thế thì nghe có
lý đúng không?
Rồi các bạn nhá. Nhưng cái đây không
phải đây không phải cái thức chỉ có dân
chuyên mới đại học nhá. Các bạn lên đại
học đều phải học cái này mà. Lên đại học
các bạn học môn đại số đều phải có cái
này mà đúng không? đâu phải là chữ mỗi
chuyên người ta học cái này đâu.
Rồi tiếp nhá. Thi thoảng kiểm tra một
chút xem là cái nước toán của bạn như
nào nhá.
Có các bạn ạ. À vậy có bạn nào hỏi là có
người ta có cái mô hình người ta có
thuật toán để người ta huấn luyện dân
trên cái mô hình này. Thế nhưng mà cái
đấy là phần có lẽ chúng ta sẽ để phần
phía sau. Cái này thì ờ nó liên quan đến
mảng NLP nhá. Nó liên quan đến mảng NP.
Có trong cái word word meding này không
phải tên của một thuật toán nó là tên
của cảm cái họ rất nhiều thuật toán word
thì là từ meding thì là nhúng đúng
không? T người ta sẽ nhúng những cái từ
này thành biến đổi thành những cái vecơ
được chưa? Có thuật toán ấy không phải
ngẫu nhiên nó thành những cái vecơ này
đâu mà nó phải quá trình huấn luyện
người ta phải dùng rất nhiều dữ liệu để
ta huấn luyện những cái mô hình này.
Được chưa? Thế nhưng mà sau khi huấn
luyện xong thì sau khi huấn luyện xong
với rất nhiều dữ liệu thì cái mô hình
này nó sẽ có khả năng nó sẽ biểu diễn
các cái vecơ các cái từ chúng ta thấy
những cái vecơ như thế này. Đấy và ví dụ
các bạn có từ lion với từ tiger chẳng
hạn thì góc kẹp giữa nó sẽ rất là bé.
Được chưa? Thế thì trong cái gooding này
ấy nó sẽ có ba cái hệ mô hình lớn. Nó có
ba cái hệ mô hình nổi tiếng nhất nhá.
Nói qua cho các bạn nhá. Nói qua nói qua
một chút nhá. What
aming
được chưa? Nó sẽ có ba hệ nổi tiếng. Một
là các cái mô hình word to v. Word to v.
Vect là vecor đấy. Hai là globe.
Glob là cái găng tay đấy. Và ba là fast
nhá. Và hệ mô hình nổi tiếng. Thì bây
giờ mình sẽ nói qua bạn về hai cái mô
hình sau. Được chưa? Cái mô hình đầu thì
nó không có một cái trang cụ thể thì nó
sẽ hơi khó. Còn hai mô hình sau thì dễ
hơn. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Ví dụ Glob này.
Glob nhá. Đây là một cái mô hình của đại
học Stanford. Đây này. Đây này. Stanford
này. Được chưa? Đây một cái mô hình nó
rất là nổi tiếng. Cái thời ngày nay các
bạn sẽ ít khi các bạn nghe thấy nó tại
vì bây giờ AI nó quá phát triển, NLP nó
quá phát triển, nó có mô hình ngôn ngữ
lớn rồi. Bây giờ thường những ai học về
AI người ta ít khi người ta động đến mô
hình này. Nhưng mà cái thời ngày xưa của
mình cái 10 năm đ mô hình rất là nổi
tiếng và nó chính là cái nền tảng của
các cái mô hình sau này. Ví dụ bạn nào
các bạn dùng các cái các bạn làm việc
với các cái agent hoặc là Rủng các thứ
các bạn sẽ có biết cái trang này đúng
không? Olama được chong trong nó là nơi
mà chúng ta sẽ có cái những mô hình ngôn
ngữ lớn chúng ta tự host đấy, tự host
trên máy của chúng ta. Nhưng nó có một
cái nhánh làding. Đây là các cái mô hình
giúp các bạn có thể mã hóa các cái văn
bản, các cái đoạn tích thành những cái
vecơ cố định. Thì những cái mô hình này
tiền thân của nó chính là những cái mô
hình word eding như thế này. Đây tiền nó
là như thế này. Nhưng cái mô hình này nó
chỉ có khả năng nó được từng từ thôi.
Sau này thì các cái mùi ngôn ngữ lớn nó
mới có khả năng nó có thể được cả một
cái đoạn văn. Được chưa? Thế thì mày các
bạn nhìn này, người ta phải huấn luyện
những cái mùi này với rất nhiều dữ liệu.
Ví dụ các bạn nhìn đây nhá. Ví dụ các
bạn nhìn đây nhá. Được chưa? Ví dụ đầu
tiên này người ta huấn luyện nó với một
cái bộ là cái bộ tên là bộ Wikipedia
2014 cộng với bộ Gearw 5 này. Cái bộ này
nó có 6 tỷ token. Toen nó là cái gì? Các
bạn tạm v các bạn hiểu đơn giản. Toầ là
các cái từ. Tức là tổng cộng lại người
ta đếm tổng cộng số lượng từ của tất cả
những cái văn bản nó được khoảng 6 tỷ.
Được chưa? À người ta sẽ một cái bộ
vocabary tức là cái bộ từ điển nó bao
gồm 400.000 nghìn tử không phân biệt chữ
hoa chữ thường. Được chưa? Ờ đây là cái
số chiều đầu ra của cái vecơ 50 chiều,
100 chiều, 200 chiều, 300 chiều. Tạm
thời các bạn chưa cần phải quan tâm là
nó luyện như nào. Chỉ biết là ra là gì?
Là cái bộ này nó sẽ có cái khả năng nó
mã hóa được 400.000 từ khác nhau đúng
không? Và nó không phê bệ chữ hoa chữ
thường ra cái output như này. Cái bộ thứ
hai là bộ common craw này.
Vì sao? Tại vì như này. Tại vì như này.
Toen là cái gì? Thì ví dụ các bạn có cái
à đây
các bạn có cái từ là à các bạn có từ là
ờ
ờ cái gì nhỉ?
Ờ
a mouse
is tracing
my
mouse đúng không? Một con chuột nó đang
đuổi theo cái chuột máy tính của tôi
đúng không? Thế thì các bạn nhìn này,
nếu mà nói về token ấy thì một token
này, hai token này, ba token này, bốn
token này, 5 token này, 6 toen không nói
về toen th 6 nhưng nói về vocaby nó chỉ
có 5 thôi. Hai này nó tính là 1 đúng
không? Vocaby là cái quyển từ điển của
các bạn đúng không nó xuất hiện nhiều nó
cũng chỉ tính là 1 thôi. Nên là số lượng
token bao giờ cũng nhiều hơn số lượng
vocabulary đúng không? Cái từ cái từ mau
này nó suy 100 lần trong cái vocaby nó
chỉ là một thôi. Nhưng trong cái ờ nhưng
trong cái token nó sẽ là 100 từ. Được
chưa? Nên là bao giờ cái số lượng token
các bạn nó sẽ lớn hơn rất là nhiều. Được
chưa? 6 tỷ token đúng không? Vabb. Được
chưa? Cái bộ thứ hai là comment craw.
Cái bộ này là cái bộ phiên bản bé nó bao
gồm 42 tỷ token b là billion đấy đúng
không? 42 tỷ token đó chư. Vocabary nó
có 1,9 triệu. Được chưa? Tiếng Anh thôi.
Nó toàn tiếng Anh thôi. Được chưa? Không
phân biệt chữ hoa chữ thường. Cái vết
đầu ra có 300 chiều được chưa? Cái bộ
lớn hơn này
nó không cố định các bạn ạ. Nó không cố
định. cố định số chiều càng nhiều nó
biểu nó biểu diễn được càng nhiều ý
nghĩa nhưng mà cái thời gian để load nó
sẽ càng lâu. Được chưa? Bộ tiếp theo là
comment core này nó được huấn luyện dựa
trên cái bộ rượu tương đương với 840 tỷ
token đúng không? Vocabuly là 2,2 triệu
nhưng mà phân biệt phân biệt chữ hoa chữ
thường đúng không? Chữ hoa chữ thường nó
sẽ khác nhau đúng không? Từ go chữ G
viết hoa với từ go chữ G viết thường nó
sẽ khác nhau. 300 chiều đầu ra ra cái
output này đúng không? Và cuối cùng là
cái bộ liên quan đến Twitter. Bộ
Twitter. Twitter nó bao gồm 2 tỷ dòng
tweet được chưa? 2 tỷ su này tổng cộng
là có 27 tỷ token này. Vocab là có 1,2
triệu ra được cái output là 25 chiều
hoặc là 50 hoặc 100 200. Các bạn lấy cái
phiên bản càng nhiều chiều thì cái ý
nghĩa nó lại càng dầu. Thế nhưng mà cái
thời gian load nó sẽ càng lâu. Được
chưa? Thế thì những cái những cái vecơ
được tạo ra nó sẽ có đặc điểm là gì? Các
bạn nhìn nhá. Ví dụ bây giờ mình lấy cái
vecơ của từ fru mình sẽ tìm xem là trong
cái bộ 400.000 Nhìn từ này cái từ những
từ nào là những từ có cái vecơ tương
đồng nhất với cái vecơ của từ fr này.
Thì đây là bảy cái từ như vậy. Thì các
bạn thấy không? Bảy cái từ này nó đều
liên quan đến loại X. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
là những cái từ này nó hay xuất hiện
cùng cùng trong cùng hoàn cảnh. Ví dụ sẽ
có những cái văn bản là litoria là một
giống ếch sống ở Nam Mỹ chẳng hạn. Ví dụ
như vậy đúng không? Thì cái từ này với
cái từ flop nó hay duyện giống hay duện
cùng ngự cảnh với nhau. Thế nên là cái
góc nên là chúng nó tương đồng nhau.
Tương đồng nhau có nghĩa là gì? Các bạn
nhìn này tương đồng nhau. Ví dụ đây
trong không gian hai chiều được chưa? Ví
dụ đây trong không gian hai chiều nhá.
Trong thực tế nó sẽ không gian 100, 200,
300 chiều nhưng mà nhiều hơn ba chiều
mình không vẽ được nên mình đưa về không
gian ít chiều mình vẽ. Được chưa? Một
ông này ví dụ đây ông này là ông Lion
này. Ông này là ông Tiger này. Được
chưa? Tiger được chưa? Thì góc này nó sẽ
bé. Góc này bé làm sao để biết góc này
nó bé hay nó lớn thì nó sẽ dùng cái khái
niệm là gì? Người ta gọi là cos
simulity. Ngày xưa các bạn học rồi đúng
không? Tích vũ ngoài vectơ. Vectơ u nhân
vectơ vằng cái gì nào?
Vectơ u nhân vectơ v bằng cái gì?
Vectơ u nhân vectơ v tích vuông của
vectơ bằng
gì nhỉ? Tích vô hướng của vectơ.
Đúng rồi. Bằng giá đúng không? Độ dài
chưa? Giá của vectơ u nhân với giá của
vectơ v nhân với cosin góc alpha kẹp
giữa đúng không? Thế nên bây giờ ấy mình
sẽ đổi mình sẽ chuyển cosin của al cos
của alpha cos của alpha sẽ bằng là tích
vô hướng của hai ông chia cho tích của
giá của hai vecơ đúng không? Và tất
nhiên là gì? Cái giá trị này sẽ luôn nằm
trong khoảng từ 0 cho đến 1 đúng không?
Góc alpha góc càng bé thì cos càng lớn
đúng góc alpha càng bé thì cosin nó càng
lớn đúng không? Thế nên là cái góc alpha
mà gần với 0 ấy thì cosin gần với 1 đúng
không? Cái này người ta gọi là cos
simulity đúng không? Tí viện mình gọi là
cosin đấy. Cos
similarity đúng không? là gì? Góc kẹp
giữa càng bé thì hai vectơ nó càng tương
đồng nhau thì hai cái từng nó càng tương
đồng nhau đúng không? Và nó sẽ đánh giá
bằng c cosin cosin của góc cosin của cái
góc kẹp giữa nó càng lớn thì cái góc nó
càng bé. Được chưa? Đấy thì đây các bạn
nhìn này. Đây là các cái bảy danh sách
của bảy cái từ và nó có cái cái cosity
với cả cái vecơ của từ for này nó lớn
nhất đúng không? Thì có nghĩa là gì? Có
nghĩa là khi mình dùng những cái mô hình
như kiểu là word anding như này ấy thì
không những chúng ta có khả năng chúng
ta phân biệt giữa từ này với từ kia. Tại
vì là hai từ khác nhau thì bao giờ nó
cũng sẽ ra được hai cái vecơ khác nhau
đúng không? bao giờ nó cũng sẽ ra được
hai vectơ khác nhau. Thế nhưng mà ngoài
việc nó ra được hai vectơ khác nhau, nó
còn thể hiện cái mức độ ý nghĩa, cái mức
độ gần gũi về mặt ý nghĩa nữa. Gần gũi
về mặt ý nghĩa. Đấy là cái thứ nhất. Cái
thứ hai nữa là gì? Là các cái vecơ này ấ
nó cũng có khả năng nó cộng trừ như
vectơ toán học bình thường. Tức là gì?
Tức là nếu các bạn một cái ví dụ đây các
bạn này. Nếu các bạn lấy cái vecơ của từ
king trừ đi từ queen nó sẽ xấp xỉ với
các bạn lấy cái vecơ của từ man trừ đi
woman. Xấp xỉ vecơ của từ sir trừ đi
madam. Đấy, xuất của của của father trừ
đi mother, của uncle trừ đi aunt, của
brother trừ đi sister đúng không? Các
các cái ccơ này sẽ xấp xỉ nhau nên nó sẽ
xấp xỉ nhau. Được chưa? Đây là cái thứ
mà chúng ta trong trong trong số vecơ
trong số học chúng ta làm được và vectơ
trong đây nó cũng làm được y chang như
vậy đúng không? Hoặc các bạn lấy cái
vecơ của từ strong trừ đi stronger nó
lại xấp xỉ vecơ của từ clear trừ đi
clearer, soft trừ đi softer hay là dark
trừ đi darker. Được chưa? chúng nó sẽ
xấp xỉ nhau. Được chưa? Đây là những cái
thông tin quý giá mà sau này lại giúp
cho những cái mô hình đặc biệt những cái
mô hình trong bảng NLP nó có thể học
được cái mối quan hệ giữa các cái từ
được không? Onehot không làm được.
Onehot các cái vecơ nó sẽ đôi một nó
vuông góc với nhau chả học được cái gì
cả. Lion với Tiger hay là lion với Dog
chẳng hạn nó chả khác gì nhau cả đúng
không? Nó đều vuông góc đôi một với
nhau. Chúng ta sẽ không biết được là cái
từ nó có gần gũi với nhau hay không.
Nhưng đây thì chúng ta lại biết đúng
không? Thế là gì? Chúng ta bình thường
là con người. Chúng ta nhìn các cái từ
với nhau chúng ta biết là gì? Lion với
Tiger gần gũi, Lion với cả Airplane
chẳng hạn nó chả liên quan đến nhau đúng
không? Con người chúng ta biết. Thế bây
giờ chúng ta làm sao để chúng ta cho máy
H nó cũng biết được thì chính là nhờ
những cái wording, wording này đúng
không? Chính là nhờ những cáiing vector
này đúng không? Chúng ta thể hiện các
cái từ bằng các cái vecơ và cái góc giữa
các cái vecơ này thể hiện cái mức độ gần
gũi về mặt ý nghĩa, gần gũi về mặt ngữ
cảnh của chúng. Được chưa?
Cái mô hình này nó lại chỉ có tiếng Anh
thôi. Nó chỉ có tiếng Anh thôi. Thì bây
giờ muốn các nhiều thứ nhiều nhiều thứ
tiếng nữa thì năm 2010
2016 2017 đấy chúng ta có một cái mô
hình của Facebook. Bây giờ là Meta nó là
mô hình Fastch. Fasttech này nó support
157 ngôn ngữ khác nhau. Đây các bạn nhìn
này. Nó có rất nhiều ngôn ngữ khác nhau
và những cái môn ngữ này nó đều là cái
số chiều là 300 nhá. Tất cả đều số chiều
là 300. Các bạn nhìn nó như này. Đấy các
bạn mà lấy một cái file bất kỳ ví dụ các
bạn có tiếng Việt nhá. Các bạn mà down
cái file đây nó sẽ một file nó nặng
khoảng 4 GB. Các bạn mở nó ra nó sẽ là
một cái file nó có rất là nhiều hàng.
Mỗi một hàng tương ứng với một từ trong
tiếng Việt. Đ không giếng Việt mình có
100.000 từ nó sẽ có 100.000 hàng và nó
sẽ có 301 cột. Vì sao lại là 301? Cái
cột đầu tiên là cái từ gốc 300 cột sau
là
cái vecơ tương ứng đúng không? Thì bây
giờ sau này khi mà người ta gần mã hóa
các cái từ trong tiếng Việt người ta chỉ
cần xem là cái từ đấy nó ở cái hàng nào.
Chúng ta lấy đúng cái hàng này ra lấy
300 cái giá trị của vectơ ra. Thế là
xong. Được chưa?
Đây gọi là word medding. Nó chính là
tiền thân của các cái ing model các cái
mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn eding sau này. Đấy
các mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn sau này là
người ta sẽ được cả một cái đoạn văn thì
nó nó chính là phiên bản phiên bản
premium của các cái mô hình wording ngày
xưa này. Được chưa?
Cái này sau này các bạn khi nào các bạn
đi sâu mảng NLP các bạn sẽ
có cơ hội chúng ta sẽ nói thêm nhá. Được
chưa? Còn về data maching tiêu chuẩn thì
các bạn chỉ biết qua như vậy thôi. Tức
là có những cái mô hình nó giúp chúng ta
có thể số hóa các cái từ thành các cái
vecơ và cái mối quan hệ cái cái cái
khoảng cách cái không phải khoảng cách
mà cái góc giữa các cái vecơ này nó sẽ
thể hiện xem là các cái từ tương ứng nó
gần gũi hay là nó khác biệt nhau. Được
chưa?
Rồi các bạn đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì
không? Đây chỉ minh họa nhá. Trong thực
tế các bạn sẽ không mượ qua chữ quân hóa
nữa đâu. Tại vì sao? Trong công gian
thực tế nó sẽ rất nhiều chiều b nó phải
25 chiều 50 chiều 100 200 300 mà quá ba
chiều các bạn không mờ các bạn chị văn
hóa được. Đây chỉ phiên bản đơn giản
thôi. Được chưa?
>> Chị muốn hỏi là nếu như một từ mà nó có
hai nghĩa ví dụ như từ fly á
>> là vừa là con ruồi nhưng mà nó vừa là
bay thì nó sẽ xuất hiện ở hai dòng khác
nhau hơn.
lại đây chính là một cái nhược điểm của
các cái mô hình embedding này. Cái kiểu
này người ta gọi là embedding tĩnh,
người ta gọi là static embedding. Tức là
gì? Tức là một cái từ đấy nó sẽ luôn
luôn chỉ ra một vecơ thôi. Thế nhưng mà
đúng là có trường hợp là gì? Là có những
cái từ nó sẽ có nhiều nghĩa. Ví dụ là từ
mouse nó vừa là con chuột thật, nó vừa
là con chuột máy tính hoặc là từ bank.
Từ bank vừa là ngân hàng vừa là cái bờ
sông đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ khi mà
dùng những cái mô hình này ấy thì nó sẽ
luôn luôn output ra đúng cái vecơ đấy.
Thế nên là bây giờ ví dụ trong một cái
câu mà nó có cả cái từ bank tức là tôi
vừa rút tiền từ ngân hàng tôi đi bộ tôi
ra bờ sông tôi đi bộ chẳng hạn thì hai
cái từ bank này mô hình nó sẽ không phân
biệt được nó sẽ không phân biệt được
chúng thì đấy là cái nhược điểm của
những cái mô hình như này. Do đó sau này
người ta mới có những cái mô hình người
ta sẽing động tức là dynamic eding tức
là gì? Tức là bây giờ tôi ờ tôi tôi số
hóa một cái từ ấy, tôi sẽ không chỉ nhìn
vào cái từ đấy, tôi sẽ nhìn vào cả cái
từ xung quanh nó nữa. Thế nên là bây giờ
cùng là cái từ đấy đồ vào nhưng mà chúng
ta sẽ có nhiều cái em vecơ đồ ra tại vì
là các cái từ xung quanh chúng nó khác
nhau. Cái từ xung quanh của con chuột
thật nó sẽ khác. Cái từ xung quanh của
con chuột máy tính nó sẽ khác. Và kể cả
giữa hai cái từ con trut thuật thì trong
hai cái câu khác nhau nó cũng sẽ ra
những cái vecơ khác nhau. Đấy thì đấy
gọi là dynamicing. Thế nhưng mà cái
phiên bản cái phiên bản đời đầu ngày xưa
này người ta chưa làm được điều đấy. Một
từ nó chỉ có một vecơ thôi. Bất kể nó có
nhiều nghĩa hay nó có một nghĩa.
Rồi
có bạn nào câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào
>> anh ơi? Vậy trong cái mảng hai chiều này
thì mấy cái vecơ này chắc không dùng
được anh nhỉ? Ờ ừ. Cái gì ấy nhở? Mảng
mảng mảng hay chưa làm sao nhỉ?
>> Tức là cái bảng số liệu theo kiểu
thì bảng mà anh showu ra đây bảng nhà
đất giá nhà này rồi gì đấy mà thì có cái
dữ liệu dạng chữ như này thì mình cũng
không làm mình chắc là mình cũng phải
làm cách nào không thể chuyển thành vecơ
được anh nhỉ? Chỉ để mã hóa thích kiểu
số khác thôi.
>> Cái bảng này
>> như vậy.
>> Cái bảng này nó nó là số sẵn rồi. Bảng
này nó là số sẵn rồi.
>> Cái
>> không lúc nãy anh giới thiệu
các màu ấy thì
>> à
màu này á
>> thì không có dụng được anh nhỉ?
>> Cái này dùng thì dùng được. Cái này dùng
thì được dùng được. Tức là khi mà chúng
ta có khi chúng ta có ít giá trị khác
nhau ấy người ta có thể dùng onhot.
Nhưng mà khi mà có nhiều giá trị quá thì
thường người ta sẽ không dùng. Cái cái
cái vấn đề thế này tức là cái onhot nó
được cái là nó đơn giản nó đơn giản và
thường nó sẽ nhanh. Ờ số chiều của nó ví
dụ mình có khoảng vài chục giá trị khác
nhau thì mình dùng onhot cho nó nhanh.
Thế còn cáiing ấy cái vừa nãy
ữu ích khi nào? Nó chỉ hữu ích khi mà
chúng ta ừ thứ nhất là chúng ta cần
thông tin về mặt ý nghĩa của các cái giá
trị. Cái ý nghĩa của giá trị tức là từ
này từ kia nó gần nhau từ kia nó khác
nhau. Mà cái thứ hai nữa cái quing này
ấy thì số chiều nó luôn luôn rất rất là
nhiều. Thông thường sẽ phải 50 chiều,
100 chiều, 200 chiều, 300 chiều và load
nó cũng sẽ rất là lâu. Load nó cũng rất
là lâu. Và cái nữa là gì? Nó sẽ chỉ hữu
ích khi mà nó dùng để mã hóa các cái từ
mà trong từ điển. Ví dụ bây giờ mình có
một một cái cột là về các cái mã mã gói
hàng đúng không? Có một gói hàng là XTD,
một gói hàng là Mun24 đúng không? Thì
cái mã như vậy ấ chúng ta sẽ không dùng
mô hình được. Tại vì là trong từ điển nó
không có những cái từ đấy đúng không?
Nhưng nó chỉ phù hợp khi mà những cái từ
đấy nó thực sự những cái từ nó xuất hiện
trong từ điển trong ngôn ngữ của con
người thôi. Còn nếu nó là những cái mã
hàng hóa chẳng hạn thì người ta sẽ không
dùng được. Người ta sẽ phải dùng cái
hoặc là on on hot hoặc là cách nào khác.
Đấy nhá.
>> Anh ơi giả sử như là cái onh hot này thì
đưa vào bảng như nào anh?
>> À thì onhot này thì bây giờ lúc đầu nó
là một cột ra output nó sẽ là bốn cột.
>> Thế bây giờ mình có một cột mình sẽ có
bốn cột.
Đúng không? Output nó vẫn là bảng mà.
Xin
>> lỗi thầy ch để cho nó tất cả những gì mà
thầy nói từ nãy đến giờ là nó thuộc về
cái phần nào trong cái bảng đầu tiên ấy
nhở. Trong cái principle cái workflow
đầu tiên là để statistic hả?
Nó nó là cái bước tiền xử lý ạ. Bước
tiền xử lý tiền xử lý.
>> Vâng. Tiền xử lý.
Tiền xử lý một là đưa các cái dữ liệu
dạng categorical về cái dạng mà máy nó
có thể hiểu được dạng số và hai là chúng
ta đưa cái dệu dạng số về cái dạng mà mô
hình nó sẽ dễ làm việc, nó sẽ làm việc
thuận lợi hơn, dễ hội tụ hơn.
>> Ừ.
>> Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Tiếp nhá các bạn nhá. Nhớ nhá. Trong
thực tế cái số chiều nó sẽ nhiều hơn rất
là nhiều các bạn nhá. Đây chỉ là trong
không gian ba chiều là chúng ta vẽ minh
họa thôi. Trong thực tế chúng ta sẽ
không bao giờ chúng ta trực tiếp chúng
ta minh chế văn hóa đâu. Tại vì nó không
ra nhiều chiều lắm. Thông thường cái
chiều tiêu chuẩn là 300 chiều ta thường
ta dùng 300 chiều. 300 là nó trung hòa
giữa việc là số chiều nhiều hơn nữa thì
người ta cũng làm được nhưng mà chiều
nhiều hơn nữa thì lốp nó sẽ rất là lâu.
Hôm tờ chúng ta sẽ có một cái muốn sẽ có
một cái bài tập về nhà về cái phần
mining này. Đấy ngay ờ buổi buổi tón sau
cho các bạn b tập về nhà về cái ming này
các bạn sẽ thử ờ load mô hình này các
bạn thấy là nếu mà các bạn load cái mô
hình 300 chiều nó sẽ lâu hơn rất là
nhiều so với cái mô hình có 50 chiều.
Thế nhưng mà bù lại 300 chiều nó sẽ có
nhiều ý nghĩa hơn cái độ chính xác nó sẽ
cao hơn.
Rồi cái đấy là về các cái bước liên quan
đến tiền xử lý dữ liệu đúng không? Tiền
dữ liệu chúng ta xử lý dạng dạng dạng
dạng numeric rồi đúng không? Trong
categorical chúng ta lại có dạng nominal
với cả dạng ordinal rồi đúng không? Thế
ngoài ra nó còn có nhiều kiểu khác nữa
lắm nhưng mà đây là kiểu nó phổ biến
nhất mà các bạn sẽ hay dùng nhất mà
trong quá trình chúng ta học chúng ta đi
làm sau này chúng ta sẽ có thể chúng ta
sẽ tìm hiểu kiểu khác nữa đúng không như
đây là những kiểu signature trong machin
rồi được chưa
tiếp các bạn nhá tiếp chúng ôi sao sao ừ
có số đây
tiếp nhá chúng ta sẽ nói về một cái khái
niệm nữa liên quan đến correlation đây
lại là một cái khái niệm trong mô thống
kê đúng không correlation tiếng Việt
mình gọi là cái gì các À coation tiếng
Việt mình gọi là cái gì các bạn?
Coration là cái gì?
Coration đúng rồi. Tương quan. Đúng rồi.
Tương quan các bạn nhá. Khi mà các bạn
muốn sá thất thống kê chúng ta sẽ có một
cái đệp là
biến ngẫu nhiên nhiều chiều đúng không?
Thường nhiều chiều người ta hay học về
hai chiều đúng không? Ví dụ biến ngẫu
nhiên hai chiều biến x biến y đúng
không? Chúng ta sẽ đánh giá cái mức độ
thay đổi của hai cái biến này với nhau
thì người ta sẽ có một cái khái niệm là
coration. Công thức thì như các bạn nhìn
thấy đây. Công thức thì như các bạn nhìn
thấy được chưa? Công thức này. Công thức
này các bạn có thể các bạn không nhớ
cũng được, các bạn không biết cách tính
cũng thì cũng không sao lắm. Tại vì sau
này thư viện nó đã làm hộ các bạn. Được
chưa? Thư viện nó sẽ làm hộ các bạn. Thì
công thức này ấ bạn nào mà các bạn học
về sáu thống kê các bạn sẽ biết cái đây
cái hệ số này là người ta gọi là hệ số.
Cái chữ này cũng không phải chữ R đâu,
nó là chữ row. Nhưng mà mình gõ máy mình
cũng không có cái nào mình gõ ra cái chữ
đấy mình gõ tạm vào chữ R đây. Nhưng mà
đây là nó không phải là kiệu chữ R nó là
ký hiệu Row. Được chưa? Đây là cái hệ
số. Hệ số là hệ số tương quan.
Hệ số tương quan của hai biến nó sẽ là
một cái giá trị nằm trong khoảng từ -1
cho đến 1. Được chưa? Hệ số tương quan
của hai biến nằm trong khoảng từ -1 đến
1. Nhìn qua một tí nhá. Cái công thức ở
cái tử cái công thức ở phía trên này thì
thường người ta ít khi người ta dùng
trực ít khi người ta dùng trực tiếp sẽ
dùng công thức ở dưới. COV là cái gì các
bạn? COV của XY nó là cái gì? COV là
viết tắc của cái gì?
COV là viết tắc của
>> covariance. Đúng rồi. Hiệp phương sai
đúng không? Cái điện là hiệp phương sai.
Còn mẫu số là
độ lệ chuẩn của x nhân với độ l chuyển
của y. Đóng cái váy lại là gì? Hệ số
tương quan của hai biến sẽ là một cái
giá trị nó luôn luôn nằm trong khoảng từ
-1 cho đến 1 và lấy cả hai đầu mút. Được
chưa? Luôn nằm trong khoảng từ -1 lấy cả
hai đầu mút. Hệ số tương quan nó có ý
nghĩa gì? Hệ số tương quan của hai biến
nó thể hiện cái mức độ mà 2 hay là nhiều
biến. Thường là hai cho dễ đi. Mức độ
hai biến thay đổi tuyến tính cùng với
nhau. Tuyến tính là mối quan hệ gì?
Tuyến tính là mối quan hệ bậc 1. Ngày
xưa các bạn học cái hàm tuyến tính là
hàm y = ax + b đấy. Đúng không? Thì x
với y thì mối quan hệ của chúng chính là
mối quan hệ tuyến tính đấy. Đúng không?
y = ax + b thì mối quan hệ giữa x y
chính là mối quan hệ tuyến tính. Được
chưa? Chính là mối quan hệ tuyến tính.
Thế thì
cái mối quan hệ tuyến tính ấy, cái mối
quan hệ tuyến tính nếu có nếu có tồn tại
ấy nó sẽ có hai kiểu, một là đồng biến
và hai là nghịch biến. Được chưa? Thì
cái hệ số tương quan này thứ nhất là nó
giúp chúng ta đánh giá xem là hai biến
ấy liệu chúng nó có mối quan hệ tuyến
tính hay không và nếu có thì mối quan hệ
đấy nó có mạnh hay không nhá. Nó đánh
giá là hai biến có mối quan hệ tuyệt hay
không và nếu có thì nó có mạnh hay
không. Nếu mà cái hệ số tương quan giữa
hai biến ấy nó gần một thì có nghĩa là
hai cái biến này có mối quan hệ tuyệt
tính với nhau mạnh và theo chướng hướng
đồng biến. Đồng biến nghĩa là gì? Đồng
biến nghĩa là ông tăng thì tôi tăng mà
ông giảm thì tôi giảm. Thế còn nếu cái
hệ sốt tương quan này nó gần với -1 có
nghĩa là hai biến này nó vẫn có mối quan
hệ tuyến tính nhưng theo kiểu nghịch
biến. Nghịch biến tức là ông tăng thì
tôi giảm mà ông giảm thì tôi tăng. Còn
hệ số tương quan mà gần không ấy thì có
nghĩa là hai cái biến này gần như chúng
nó không có mối quan hệ tuyến tính. Được
chưa? Nhắc lại nhá. Hệ số tương quan
giữa hai biến giúp chúng ta đánh giá xem
cái mức độ quan hệ tuyến tính, mức độ
quan hệ bậc một giữa hai biến nó mạnh
hay là nó yếu và nó theo cái hướng nào
đúng không? Gần 1 là theo hướng dương,
gần -1 là theo hướng âm. Hướng dương tức
là đồng biến ông tăng tôi tăng, ông giảm
tôi giảm. Hướng âm tức là nghịch biến
ông tăng tôi giảm. Còn nếu hệ số tương
quan bằng 0, nếu hệ số tương quan bằng 0
thì nghĩa là hai biến này hoàn toàn
không có mối của hệ tuyến tính. Trước
quân hóa các bạn nhìn đây, chữ quân hóa
đây đúng không? Nếu x là một một biến, y
là một biến nhá đúng không? Thì số t
bằng 0,7 nó trông như này. Tức là gì?
Các cái điểm đó nó sẽ nằm gần với một
cái đường thẳng. Được chưa? Nó nằm gần
một cái đường thẳng. Hệ dung tức qua mà
nhỏ hơn nó sẽ bắt đầu nó sẽ phân tán ra
đúng không? Hệ dung tố qua bằng 0 có
nghĩa là gì? Hai ông hai biến nó không
có mối ngệ tấn tính. Ông tăng thì có thể
tôi tăng, ông tăng thì có thể tôi giảm
đúng không? Đấy, còn hệ số tương quan mà
âm như này. Âm thì nó như này. Được
chưa? Âm bằng -0,7 này, -0,3 với cả 0
như này. Được chưa? Thế nhưng với hệ số
tương quan có một vài cái điểm các bạn
cần chú ý nhá. Có một vài cái điểm cần
chú ý. Thông thường nhá, thông thường ấy
khi mà từ giờ trở về sau nhá, khi mà
mình nói là hai biến có hệ số tương quan
lớn thì các bạn hiểu là gì? Các bạn hiểu
ý của mình là gì? Là cái hệ số tương
quan nó gần 1 hoặc nó gần -1 nhá. Được
chưa? Khi mình nói là quan hệ tuyến tính
của hai biến nó mạnh hoặc là hệ số thông
số quan của hai biến nó lớn thì ý của
mình là nó nói gì? Mình nói là cái trị
tuyệt đối của nó lớn tức là nó gần 1 và
nó gần tr-1. Thông thường ấy thì hệ số
tương quan của hai biến mà trên 0,7 hoặc
là dưới -0 -0,7 hay nói khác là gì? Chi
tuyệt đối của hệ số tương quan lớn hơn
0,7 thì đấy được coi là hai biến có quan
hệ tuyến tính mạnh với nhau. Được chưa?
Nếu trị tuyệt đối của hệ số tương quan
lớn hơn 0,7 thì đấy được coi là hai biến
có mức độ tuyến tính mạnh với nhau. Được
chưa? Thế cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai là
gì? Là tương quan. Mối quan hệ tương
quan và mối quan hệ nhân quả là hai cái
thứ nó khác nhau nhá. Tương quan và nhân
quản khác nhau khác nhau. Tương quan hai
cái biến có hệ số tương quan lớn ấy chỉ
thiện là gì? là hình bên này nó có mức
độ biến thiên cùng nhau. Ông tăng tôi
tăng, ông giảm tôi giảm hoặc là ông tăng
tôi giảm ngược lại chứ nó không có ý
nghĩa là ông này gây ra ông kia. Ví dụ
ví dụ bây giờ có hai cái biến. Một biến
thể hiện GDP của Việt Nam 50 năm vừa
qua, một biến thể hiện GDP của Trung
Quốc 50 năm vừa qua. Thì khi mà hai cái
biến này ấy có cái hệ số tương quan lớn
ví dụ như là 0,9 chẳng hạn thì nó chỉ
thể hiện cái điều gì? Nó thể hiện là
những cái năm nào mà JB GDP Việt Nam
tăng thì GB của Trung Quốc nó cũng tăng.
Và năm nào mà JB Việt Nam giảm thì của
Trung Quốc nó vẫn giảm. Tức là gì? Hay
ông biến thiên cùng nhau thôi chứ nó
không thể hiện là vì ông Trung Quốc tăng
nên là ông Việt Nam tăng hay là vì ông
Trung Quốc giảm nên ông Việt Nam giảm.
Đúng nó không thể hiện điều đấy. Được
chưa? Nó không thể hiện điều đấy. Nó chỉ
thể hiện là gì? Là các cái biến nó biến
thiên cùng nhau mà thôi. Đúng không? Nó
biến thên cùng nhau. Được chưa nhá? Quan
hệ tương quan và quan hệ nhân quả là cái
thứ nó hoàn toàn nó không liên quan với
nhau. Đấy là cái thứ đấy là cái thứ hai.
Cái thứ ba là gì? Cái thứ ba là khi mà
hệ số tương quan của hai biến nó bằng 0
ấy thì có ý nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là hai
biến này nó không có mối quan hệ tuyệt
tuyến tính hay là nó không có mối quan
hệ bậc một với nhau. Nhưng điều đấy nó
không có nghĩa là hai biến này chúng nó
hoàn toàn độc lập với nhau.
Hệ dung tương qu bằng 0 chỉ có nghĩa là
gì? Là hai ông này không có quệ bậc 1
thôi. Còn nếu chúng nó có mối quan hệ
bậc hai, bậc ba là bậc gì đấy chúng ta
không có biết. Được chưa? Hệ số tương
quan nó chỉ thể hiện duy nhất mối quan
hệ bậc 1 mà thôi. Ngoài ra nó không cho
chúng ta biết thêm bất kỳ thông tin như
gì về các cái mối quan hệ phức tạp hơn
đúng không? Bậc ha, bậc 3, bậc logarit,
bậc e gì chúng ta không có biết. Được
chưa? Đấy là về hệ số tương quan
nhá. Ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Bạn nào từng học sá suất thống kê các
bạn thấy phần này nó dễ đúng không? Tại
vì các bạn đã làm quen rồi, bạn nào các
bạn chưa học hoặc các bạn quên mất rồi
thì có thể nó sẽ hơi khó với các bạn
nhá.
Tóm lại cái số thông quan nó thể có hệ
bậc 1 nhá. Tuyền tính nghĩa là bậc 1 là
một quan hệ đơn giản nhất có thể tồn tại
giữa hai biến đúng không? y = ax + b
chính là một cái ví dụ của một hệ tuyến
tính giữa x và y. Được chưa?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không các bạn?
Vì sao mình lại nói đến hệ số tương quan
thì ngay phần sau mình sẽ giải thích cho
các bạn.
Đ
rồi có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
>> Ừ.
>> Thế tại sao trong
cái dạng
học máy này mình lại phải quan tâm đến
cái mối quan mối tông quan bậc một này
>> đây đâ đây. Tí tí nữa mình sẽ giải thích
ngay. Tí mình sẽ giải thích ngay nhá.
Ngay sau trang này mình sẽ giải thích
ngay nhá.
Rồi các bạn nhìn nhá. Đúng không? Vừa
rồi mình nói về hệ số tương quan đúng
không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ bắt đầu mình
sẽ dùng nó này nhá. Mình sẽ dùng nó nhá.
Hệ số tương quan thể hiện một hệ bậc
một. Ok. Thế v các bạn nhìn này. Thế bây
giờ nhá. Ờ
thế thì
ờ nếu nếu trong cái bộ rượu của các bạn
nhá hãy giả sử trường hợp đơn giản đi là
tất cả các cái feature và tagit đều là
dạng số hoặc là các bạn đã số hóa chúng
rồi nhá. Hoặc là chúng lúc bắt đầu chúng
ta đều dạng số hoặc là các bạn đã số hóa
chúng rồi. Được chưa?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Thế bây gi các bạn nhìn này. Thế bây giờ
ấy nếu mà giữa nếu mà trong một cái bộ
dữ liệu ấy nhá, nếu một cái bộ dữ liệu
mà tồn tại mối quan hệ tuyến tính giữa
một hoặc là một vài feature với cả tagit
nhá. Nếu trong cái bộ rượu chúng ta mà
có một hoặc là một vài feature có cái hệ
số tương quan lớn với tagit. Hệ số tương
quan lớn tức là gần 1 và gần -1 nhá.
Được chưa? Nếu có một và một vài feature
có hệ số tương quan lớn với cả tit thì
đây là điều cực kỳ tốt. Tại vì sao? Tại
vì mối quan hệ tuyến một hệ số tương
quan thể hiện mối quan hệ bậc 1. Mối
quan hệ bậc một là mối quan hệ đơn giản.
Thế thì trong machining có những thuật
toán nó rất là đơn giản, nó sẽ khai thác
rất là tốt cái mối quan hệ tuyến tính
này. Thế thì khi mà cái bộ rượu chúng ta
có một hoặc một vài feature có hệ tương
quan lớn về tit ấ thì chúng ta sẽ có thể
chọn những cái tập toán nó đơn giản.
Thuật toán đơn giản nó có một cái ưu
điểm là gì? Chạy nó nhanh, nó tên tu tốn
ít tài nguyên và nó dễ giải thích.
Thuật toán nào thu đơn giản thì đến cái
buổi sau chúng ta học về các cái thuật
toán trong machining, chúng ta sẽ biết
là có những tuần nó rất là đơn giản, nó
sẽ làm việc cực kỳ hữu ích với những cái
bộ diệu như vậy. Được chưa? Thế thế đấy
là lý do vì sao chúng ta quan tâm đến
mối quan hệ này tại vì nó quan trọng.
Thế còn nếu mà một cái bộ dữ liệu mà tất
cả các cái feature đều chẳng có feature
nào có hệ số tư quan lớn với target ấy
thì lúc này chúng ta sẽ cần phải sử dụng
những cái thuật toán nó phức tạp hơn. nó
tiêu tốn nhiều tài nguyên hơn và nó khó
giải thích hơn. Đấy là lý do vì sao mà
chúng ta lại phải quan tâm đến cái mối
quan hệ tuyến tính này. Tại vì nó cho
phép chúng ta lựa chọn xem là chúng ta
sẽ dùng những mô hình đơn giản hay là mô
hình phức tạp. Thông thường mô hình đơn
giản là những cái mô hình nó sẽ hoạt
động tốt với những cái bộ dữ liệu có thế
chất tuyến tính như vậy. Còn mô hình
phức tạp nó sẽ khai thác những mối quan
hệ nó phức tạp hơn.
Được chưa? Đấy là lý do vì sao chúng tôi
quan tâm đến coration. Được chưa?
Rồi có bắt nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bác nào có thắc mắc gì không? Cụ thể
thỏi toán nào là thu toán tuyến tính,
thuậ toán nào là thu toán phi tuyến thì
buổi sau chúng ta sẽ nói nhá.
Rồi
thế vừa rồi là chúng ta nói về một hệ
tuyến tính giữa các cái feature và tagit
đúng không? Tóm lại là gì? Chúng ta rất
mong muốn là bộ rượu chúng ta có một
hoặc một vài những cái feature có hệ số
tương quan lớn với cả Tit đúng không?
Tại vì nó sẽ cho phép chúng ta chọn
những mô Anh đơn giản.
Tiếp này.
Thế còn giữa các cái feature thì sao?
Giữa các cái feature thì sao? Thì các
bạn nhìn này.
Nếu mà hệ số tương quan giữa một feature
và một tagit mà nó cao ấy là điều chúng
ta rất là mong muốn. Nhưng hệ số tương
quan lớn cho các cái feature ấy là điều
mà chúng ta không mong một chút nào. Vì
sao lại như vậy? Thì mình cho các bạn
một cái ví dụ nhá. Cho các bạn một cái
ví dụ này. Lớp mình thì hầu hết các bạn
đã hoặc là đang là sinh viên đúng không
các bạn? Thời ngày xưa các bạn lúc mà
bạn ngày xưa bạn là sinh viên hoặc các
bạn đang là sinh viên ấy, các bạn đã bao
giờ làm những cái bài tập nhóm như kiểu
là một nhóm có từ 3 đến 5 người. Thầy
cho một cái topic gì đấy rồi các bạn làm
đến cuối kỳ các bạn đi bảo vệ không? Các
bạn đã bao giờ các bạn đã từng làm cái
project như vậy chưa? Nếu mà có rồi các
bạn cho mình số một. Các bạn chưa các
bạn cho mình số 0 xem nào. Thời của mình
nó gọi là bài tập lớn. Tức là nhóm
khoảng năm ông chơi với nhau thì sẽ làm
cùng một cái nhóm đúng không? Sau nhận
đề tài của thầy. Sau đó các bạn làm một
kỳ các bạn làm bài tập. Sau đó các bạn
cuối kỳ bảo vệ đúng không? Đấy gọi là
bài bài tập lớn. Được chưa? Thế các bạn
cho mình hỏi này nhá. Thế bây giờ giả sử
bạn có nhóm rồi năm người rồi được chưa?
Các bạn nhận một cái đề tài của thầy rồi
đúng không? Thì sau khi bạn nhận đề tài
xong rồi, phân tích đề tài xong rồi thì
việc đầu tiên các bạn sẽ làm là các bạn
sẽ làm cái gì nào?
Các bạn sẽ làm cái gì?
À chia việc đúng các phân chia việc cho
năm người. Được chưa nào các bạn? Theo
các bạn chúng ta phân chia công việc như
nào thì gọi là tốt. Chúng ta phân chia
công việc cho năm người như thế nào thì
gọi là tốt.
À mỗi người một việc độc lập khác nhau
không trùng lạp. Đúng rồi. Chính xác.
Phân chia tốt là gì? Phân chia tốt là
việc gì? Là mỗi người sẽ làm cái việc
khác nhau và ông này thì không có giẫm
chân lên ông kia.
Vì sao lại như vậy? Các bạn tưởng tượng
này nhá. Bây giờ đi một nhóm có năm
người đi. Nhóm tốt là gì? Ví dụ nhóm
mình là về code đi đúng không? Một ông
lo code, một ông lo tìm hiểu lý thuyết,
một ông lo viết báo cáo, một ông lo
thuyết trình, một ông làm demo. Tức là
gì? Mỗi ông làm một việc. Mỗi việc nó sẽ
đóng góp một cái khu cho cái mục đích
chung là gì? là cái pình nó phải tốt
đúng không? Năm ông làm năm việc khác
nhau, không trùng nhau, không lặp, không
dẫn lến nhau nhưng mỗi cái đều đóng góp
cái khía cạnh gì đấy cho cái project
cuối cùng. Thì đấy là cái thứ mà chúng
ta mong muốn, đúng không? Mỗi ông nó có
một cái việc gì đấy chứ chúng ta không
muốn được một cái nhóm về năm ông trong
cái ba ông cùng ngồi cốt đúng không? Ba
ông ngồi code thì thứ nhất là nó sẽ bị
cái thì thừa, cái thì thiếu đúng không?
Cùng cái công việc đấy thì lại thừa
người trong cái công việc khác lại thiếu
đúng mà. chúng ta không muốn như vậy.
Đấy là cái lý do thứ nhất. Cái lý do thứ
hai nữa là gì? Là nếu cái công việc của
mỗi người ấy nó không bị dẫn lên nhau ấy
thì sau này ấ khi mà thầy giáo thầy muốn
chấm điểm, thầy muốn đánh giá xem là cái
project này ông nào quan trọng, ông nào
ít quan trọng ấy thì rất là dễ. Ví dụ
nhóm này ờ code tốt thì cái ông thực
hiện cái ông chữ nghiệm code điểm sẽ
cao. Nhóm kia quyển tốt thì cái ông làm
cái quyển đấy sẽ điểm cao đúng không?
Chứ còn bây giờ một nhóm mà bây giờ ba
học cùng cos thì bây giờ cái nhóm đấy mà
cos tốt đi thì bây giờ lúc thầy chấm
điểm thì cho điểm kiểu gì? Bây giờ ba
cùng cos thì làm sao thầy biết là ông
nào đóng góc nhiều, ông nào đóng góc ít
đúng không? Thì với con người như nào?
Thì với máy nó cũng y chang như vậy. Các
bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Bây giờ các bạn có
một cái bộ dữ liệu đúng không? Chúng ta
ví dụ một cái bộ rượu về dán giá nhà đi.
Các bạn có những cái thông tin là về
diện tích, về số tầng, về vị trí, về sổ
đỏ trong ngõ ngoài ngõ các thứ đúng v
đúng không? Thì chúng ta muốn là gì?
Chúng ta muốn một cái bộ rượu tốt là bộ
rượu mà mỗi một cái feature này nó sẽ
đóng góp một cái phần nào đấy trong cái
việc dự đoán giá của căn nhà đúng không?
Đấy là thứ chúng ta mong muốn và chúng
ta muốn là cái sự đóng góp nào đấy của
chúng là khác biệt nhau. Đóng góc của
ông diện tích nó sẽ khác, đóng góp của
ông số tổng nó sẽ khác, đóng góc của ông
vị trí nó sẽ khác. Chứ chúng ta không
muốn là gì? Chúng ta không muốn là các
cái phí trở khác nhau nó lại đóng góp
những thứ nó na ná nhau. Chúng ta không
muốn như thế đúng không? Mỗi ông là phải
đóng góc khác nhau chứ còn đóng góc mà
nái nhau thì cần gì phải có nhiều ông
đúng không? Ví dụ ba ông cùng cos mà cos
tương tương với nhau thì cần gì phải có
ba ông đúng không? Mà con người nào thì
máy nó cũng như thế. Thì các bạn nhìn
này cái trường hợp bên trái. Thường hợp
bên trái là cái trường hợp gì? Là hai
feature này có cái hệ số tương quan với
nhau nó thấp gần như là nó không tương
quan luôn đúng không? Thì nó các tách
biệt nhau này thì mỗi một feature nó sẽ
đóng góc một cái khí cạnh khác nhau để
dựa cái tit là cái chúng ta muốn chứ
chúng ta không muốn là gì? Chúng ta
không muốn là hai cái feature nó có cái
hệ số tương quan lớn với nhau. Tại vì hệ
số tương quan lớn chúng ta sẽ chúng nó
sẽ gây ra những cái ảnh hưởng tương tự
nhau đến cái target thì nó sẽ có cái sự
dư thừa đúng không? Và sau này nếu chúng
ta muốn quay lại chúng ta phân tích xem
là cái feature nào là feature quan trọng
thì nó sẽ khó đúng không? Cũng giống như
kiểu là bây giờ thầy muốn biết là cái
nhóm này ông nào là ông làm nhiều ông
nào là ông làm ít ấy đúng không? Thì nếu
bây giờ có những công việc nó trùng lặp
nhau thì mô hình nó sẽ không đ nó sẽ
không đánh giá được. Nó sẽ không đánh
giá được đúng không? Thì cái hiện tượng
này người ta gọi là cộng tuyến. Cộng
tuyến cộng cộng tuyến là khi các bạn chỉ
có hai feature bị như vậy thôi. Còn các
bạn có ba feature trở lên người ta gọi
là đa cộng tuyến đúng không? Tức là gì?
Là một quệ tuyền tính giữa feature với
nhau là cái điều chúng ta không mong
muốn. Chúng ta mong muốn là cái quan hệ
tuyến tính giữa feature và tagit. Được
chưa? Đấy là về đa cộng tuyến. Được
chưa?
Đang cộng tuyến nó sẽ nó sẽ gây ra cái
gì? Thứ nhất nó gây ra sự thừa thãi.
Tại vì các bạn có nhiều feature hơn thì
máy tính các kỹ thuật toán nó có thể
dùng nhiều tài nguyên hơn đúng không?
Bình thường các bạn có năm cột feature
nhưng mà lại có hai ông đa cộng tuyến
các bạn chỉ có thể bỏ một ông đi thì các
bạn chỉ có bốn feature thì máy nó sẽ nhẹ
hơn, nó sẽ tiêu tốn ít tài nguyên hơn
đúng không? Nó vừa dẫn đến cái sự lãng
phí tài nguyên, nó vừa dẫn đến sự dư
thừa. Và trong machining ấy có những cái
bài toán chúng ta không chỉ quan tâm là
cái mô hình nó dự đoán càng chính xác
càng tốt mà chúng ta còn muốn quay ngược
lại chúng ta phân tích. Ví dụ với cái
bài toán dự án giá nhà đi. Có thể người
ta sẽ không chỉ người ta quan tâm đến
việc là dữ đán giá nhà càng chính xác
càng tốt mà người ta muốn quan tâm là
gì? À tôi có thể quay ngược lại tôi giải
thích xem là là những cái căn nhà ở vị
trí nào thì nó sẽ ảnh hưởng đến nó thì
nó sẽ có cái giá nhà cao đúng không?
Hoặc những căn nhà trong cái ờ trong cái
bao nhiêu tầng chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ ảnh
hưởng đến giá nhà nó nhiều đúng không?
Thì nếu chúng ta muốn quay lại giấy như
vậy ấy thì các cái feature nó phải tách
biệt nhau chứ còn nếu các cái feature nó
đa cộng thế với nhau nó sẽ bị dính vào
nhau ấy thì chúng ta sẽ rất khó chúng ta
sẽ biệt xem là ông nào là ông quan trọng
khi mà các cái feature nó có cái khi mà
cái feature nó có cái hệ số tương quan
lớn với nhau như vậy ấy thì nó sẽ khiến
cho việc gì là có những cái feature nó
được overestimate và có những cái
feature được under bị underestimate. Tức
là gì? Bây giờ ba ông cùng code. Có thể
trong ba ông này chỉ có một ông code
chính thôi. Hai ông kia chỉ có một chơi.
Thì bây giờ khi mà thầy thầy cho điểm ấ
thầy cho một cái số điểm 8 chẳng hạn thì
tự nhiên là cái ông solo thì ông ấy lại
bị giảm cái tầm quan trọng đi. Trong khi
cái ông hai ông chả làm gì ông lại tăng
cái tầm quan trọng lên đúng không? Thì
đấy là những cái ảnh hưởng tiêu cực mà
cái hiện tượng đa cộng tuyến nó sẽ gây
ra. Được chưa?
Thế thì loại bỏ đa cọc tuyến rất là dễ
thôi. Trong hai ba ông đa cọc tuyến tôi
sẽ giữ một đồ tôi sẽ bỏ nh ông còn lại.
Được chưa? Thế nhưng mà tức là các
feature dùng để dự đoán nên
tức là các feature dùng để dự đoán nên
có hệ số tương quan
không hẳn là gần bằng 0 mà không nên cao
quá các cái các cái vure hệ số t quan
gần bằng 0 thì gần như là không thể rất
khó có chuyện là rất khó có chuyện hai
piure mà hệ dương quan đúng bằng 0 rất
là khó luôn nó chỉ nó không cao quá thôi
dưới 0,7 là ok rồi số tương quan hai
fure tại vì sao tại vì là cũng không thể
nào yêu cầu hai fure nó hoàn toàn nó
không có một tí tuyên tính với nhau nó
rất là khó. Nó rất là khó. Cái trường
hợp như vậy.
Loại bảo đa cộng tuyến thì dễ thế nhưng
mà nhưng mà có một cái điểm này là không
phải lúc nào chúng ta cũng cần loại bỏ
đa cộng tuyến. Loại bỏ đa cộng tuyến nó
chỉ hữu ích khi nào? Khi chúng ta chủ
động chúng ta dùng những mô hình tuyến
tính là những mô hình đơn giản v như
mình vừa nói ở phần trước ấy đúng không?
Những cái mô hình mà nó khai thác mạnh
vệ tuyệt tính là những cái mô hình mà
chúng ta sẽ phải nên loại bỏ đa cộng
tuyến. Thế còn nếu chúng ta đã có chủ
đích, chúng ta dùng mô hình phi tuyến
rồi thì việc loại đỏ đa cộng tuyến là
không cần thiết. Tại vì là những cái mô
hình phi tuyến, những cái mô hình phức
tạp ấy nó đằng nào nó cũng không khai
thác mối quan hệ tuyến tính nên chúng ta
có loại bỏ không thì nó cũng chả ảnh
hưởng gì. Được chưa?
Ok. Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Lý thuyết nghe hơi khó đúng không các
bạn? Bạn cố gắng lên chỉ có khoảng sáu
buổi đầu là lý thuyết thôi. Hôm nay
chúng ta đến buổi 4 rồi đúng không? S
buổi đầu lý thuyết thôi. Sau đó chúng ta
chủ yếu chúng ta thực hành thôi nhá. Sáu
buổi đầu luôn là cái buổi khó nhất nhá.
Em hỏi một câu được không anh? Có ai có
thắc mắc gì không các bạn? Có có em hỏi
một câu được không ạ? Ừ ừ em hỏi đi em
hỏi đi. Em hỏi đi.
>> Như cái hình này thì em thấy em hơi hơi
khó hiểu một chút là giả sử như cái
feature 1 và feature 2 ấ là hai cái này
đóng góp độc lập với nhau đúng không ạ?
>> Ừ không phải độc lập. Không phải độc
lập. Không phải độc lập mà nó có hệ số
tương quan thấp nhau. Thấp là gần không?
nhất chí là nó có có thể có tương quan
nhẹ với nhau nhưng mà nó đóng góp hai
cái khía cạnh khác nhau đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi, đúng rồi.
>> Vậy giờ em thắc mắc một chỗ là nếu mà
quay về cái chỗ mà
normal
cái slide lần trước ấy anh anh sa đây
>> mà mình mà chuẩn hóa số liệu ấy ạ. À
>> ví dụ như là các cái range nó rất là
rộng như thế thì nếu mà mình chuẩn hóa
xong mình cứ đưa về trong khoảng -3 đến
cộng 3 hoặc là -1 đến dương 1 ví dụ thế
thì có sợ làm cho máy nó bị
nhận định là những cái này đóng góp
giống nhau không ạ? Không không bản chất
nó đóng góc khác nhau mà
>> không ờ giống nhau hay khác nhau ấy là
phụ thuộc vào cái mức độ thay đổi của
chúng cùng với nhau. Tại vì thế này hệ
số tương quan lớn có nghĩa là ông với
tôi hoặc là tăng cng tăng giảm cng giảm
hay là ông tăng thì tôi giảm. Đấy tức là
chứ nó không phụ thuộc vào cái giải giá
trị của nó. Giải giá trị nó không ảnh
hưởng đến cái hệ số tương quan này.
Giải to hay giải bé nó không ảnh hưởng.
Nó quan trọng là hai ông thay đổi với
nhau như thế nào. Nếu mà ông tăng mà tôi
luôn tăng hoặc là ông giảm mà tôi luôn
giảm hoặc là ông tăng mà tôi luôn giảm
ấy thì hệ số tương quan nó mới lớn. Thế
còn ông tăng tôi có thể tăng tôi có thể
giảm ấy thì hệ số tương quan nó sẽ rất
là thấp. Cái cái chuẩn hóa này nó sẽ
không ảnh hưởng đến cái việc là hệ số
tương quan này.
Tại vì bản thân trong cái công thức tính
này nó bao gồm cái phần chuẩn hóa rồi.
Đây này. Cái tử số này cái covarient ấy
hiệp phương sai của hai biến là một giá
trị nằm trong khoảng từ âm vô cùng đến
dương vô cùng. Do đó chúng ta phải chuẩn
hóa ta phải chia cho tích của hai cái độ
đệ chuẩn để nó đưa về từ -1 đến 1. Tức
là gì? bản thân công thức ban đầu ấy cái
tử số này nó nằm nó đâu có giới hạn đâu.
Trong công thức này nó nó có cái sự
chuẩn hóa rồi. Thế nên là cái việc chúng
ta chuẩn hóa nó sẽ không ảnh hưởng đến
việc là đang hai cái hai cái feature
đang tương quan thấp lại thành tương
quang cao hay ngược lại nó không có cái
chuyện đấy.
Rồi
trường hợp mà các bạn làm việc với rượu
dặc bảng. Giặc bảng là những cái file
như kiểu file CSV và file Excel ấy thì
người ta sẽ thường dùng machine truyền
thống là cái nội dung của khóa này. Khóa
này sẽ tập trung vào ruệ dạng bàn được
chưa? Thế còn nếu các bạn hay làm việc
với diệu dạng văn bản hoặc là dạng ảnh
hoặc là video thì người ta sẽ dùng người
ta sẽ dùng deep learning. Tiếp đây là
cái của cái khóa sau. Tiếp này của cái
khóa sau. Còn khóa này nó tập trung vào
rượu dạng bảng cái rượu nó sẽ hay gặp
nhất.
Thì rượu bảng ấy thì bây giờ người ta sẽ
ví dụ đây thế nào gọi là vecơ? Vectơ đây
này.
Đây này. Một cái hàng này là một vectơ
này. Đây này. 60 43 này. Đây là một
vectơ này đúng không? Bỏ cái cotit đi.
60 43 là một vectơ này. 40 42 là một
vectơ này. Đấy vecơ đấy.
Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì
không?
Thế nhá. Thế bây giờ ờ tí nữa mình sẽ up
cho các bạn thứ nhất là cái solution của
bài trước mình sẽ up bài 8 nhá. Thì bảy
cái bài đầu thì các bạn hối các bạn lớp
mình nộp mình thấy bạn nào làm không
đúng cả mà có nào có cái vấn đề gì thì
đã sửa rồi đúng không? 7 đầu thì không
có cái gì cả. Bài 8 mình sẽ up cho các
bạn solution. So này là solution cũng
không phải của mình tại vì solution ngày
xưa của mình nó rất là xấu. So này là
của một cái bạn khóa trước của mình làm
tương đối là ngắn gọn mà lớp mình khóa
này thậm chí là có nhiều bạn làm còn tốt
hơn nữa cơ. Đấy thì ờ mình sẽ app cho
bạn một cái solution coi như là để các
bạn tham khảo nhá. Cái bài tá này thì
thật ra các bạn mà không làm được thì nó
cũng chả ảnh hưởng gì quá trình các bạn
học dating đâu. Chẳng qua là tại vì mình
sợ mấy cái bài bài m kia nó dễ quá mà
cho các bạn làm. Các bạn làm các bạn
thấy làm vèo cái là các bạn xong. Đấy
mình sẽ up cho cái bài mới. Bài mới chỉ
có bốn câu thôi. Bốn câu này. Bài mới
này chúng ta sẽ làm quen với 5 p.
Bốn câu này thì các bạn ba câu đầu nó
dễ. Câu cuối thì nó cũng chỉ hơi khó một
chút thôi. Cái câu cuối nó sẽ không khó
như cái buổi trước đâu. Thì một là các
bạn làm ba câu đầu, hai là các bạn làm
câu ờ câu cuối nhá. Rồi bạn nào các bạn
làm xong các bạn cứ gửi cho mình. Bài
tập tuần này thì sẽ dễ hơn tuần trước
rất nhiều. Chắc chắn là như vậy nhá.
Ờ nốt tuần sau chúng ta học lý thuyết
nữa. Sau đó tuần sau nữa chúng ta sẽ bắt
đầu chúng ta sang phần thực hành nhá.
Cố lên các bạn nhá. Cố gắng lên. Mình
biết lý thuyết nó rất là chán nhưng mà
cố gắng lên. Sang thực hành. Thực hành
nó sẽ dễ thôi. Thực hành nó không có cái
gì đâu. Thực hành rất là dễ nhá.
Nhá các bạn tin mình đi đến thực hành
các bạn thấy là so với lý thuyết từ hành
dễ hơn rất là nhiều nhá.
Ok. Có nào có câu hỏi gì